Hello everybody!
Hello!
Welcome back to Prague Vada after, oh gosh, so long!
I'm so sorry!
I don't want to yapp for too long because I do want to get
into the game.
Hello, welcome in!
Hello, hello!
What was I saying?
Oh, today the plan early stream so that I could beat the
game, but many things have occurred from the morning and my
spiritual energy is quite small so it could be more likely
than not that we'll see how much I get into the game but it
could be that I finished the game on Saturday.
I'm so sorry.
I feel so bad because like, oh my gosh, I feel like this
game is cursed.
Every time I want to play it, just something happens.
So, yeah, it was a late night for me, early morning for me
as well.
So, but thank you guys for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for your patience while I, gosh, and I also feel
so bad that took me so long to get back to the game.
I feel like my schedule at the moment is like quite packed.
It's quite overwhelmed.
Oh, chat frozen.
Thank you.
It's quite overwhelmed, so playing longer games at the
moment is a little difficult for me.
But yeah, don't push yourself to finish it today if you're
too tired.
Yeah, I'll kind of, I'll get to like the three, four hour
mark and see how I'm feeling.
And if I feel like I can keep going, then we can go.
But if I'm like, I think I'm reaching my limit, then we
will.
we will not did she get sleep I did and then early morning
and then I tried to go back to sleep and I couldn't so I've
just been like feeling so groggy I have coffee here right
now so hmm might be a little shorter than I'm thinking I
beat it last week oh really no I think though from here I
still have about seven or depending on how how much I game
so thank you for returning to prog mod aminto can't wait to
see your thoughts on the finale but also make sure to pace
yourself can't wait to see what's next for density to exe
thanks biznom hmm uh that was I gonna say yeah for 39
minutes to play the game tomorrow why 39 minutes how
specific yeah I had it we had our dents at the meeting
yesterday and oh my gosh you guys are not you guys are not
ready you guys are not ready it's complicated what does it
oh rushing it would honestly is the worst solution oh oh oh
i'm sure like yeah i don't want to technically rush anything
but at the same time i'm ready to move on as fun as this
game is i think like because uh my schedule is so all over
the place i'm kind of like in the mindset of like all right
let's Finish these things up.
And also, I'm curious about how the game ends.
So I want to finish it up, too.
But, yeah.
We'll see.
You know, I'm obviously not trying to 100% the game.
Yeah.
But let's get into...
Okay, cool.
And one thing that I really love...
Like, this game is so fun.
I really enjoyed doing the side quests on my days off and
stuff, and I haven't had time to do that.
So everything is exactly as I left it before.
I boo the unready reporting for duty.
Sprague, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
We got our campfire, we got our tree.
Was there anything that I needed to upgrade or?
Oh gosh, I was just playing the Switch yesterday, so I have
to remember that all of the X and Y are switched and things.
like that um sticky bombs let's see and where we were we are
in the we are in the mines yes we are still in the mines of
the moon the moon mines yes um but for now I think I've
upgraded I think I last time I upgraded everything I wanted
to.
Bon bon!
Thank you so much for that, thank you!
Thank you!
I do yearn for the moon mines.
Yeah, we don't have enough gold cubes to upgrade again.
Diana, I miss you so much.
You're as cute as always.
You are so cute.
And what else do we have?
I don't think anything else.
Yeah, no stamps.
But I'm not going to do the training.
Yeah.
Let's go!
I have to, so this is aim, my butt, my butt, not my buster,
my booster, my booster, my buster, my buster, I hardly even
know her.
Okie dokie.
It has been a hot minute since I last played this game, so.
We got the homing missiles, which are,
I think we're good.
I don't, I remember these, I don't like this one.
I don't like the charging stuff.
My boosters!
Boost and makes me feel good.
Actually, it does.
I don't, okay, let's see.
Impact barrier.
Yes, I want to try this.
I feel like, yeah, this is new.
I haven't been able to try it yet.
I want the bees to work.
Minto, please, it's 5 a.m.
You know what?
Not everybody lives in your time zone.
You know what it is for me?
I wish it was 5 a.m.
Obviously.
It's 3 p.m.
for me.
It's perfect for EU.
Yeah, I gotta do EU streams sometime.
So sorry though that it's like the middle of a game kind of
stream.
Oh, here we go.
Let's ride the tram.
Go back to the mines?
Crane control room.
I believe there was the worm here.
The worm.
It's always 5 a.m.
somewhere in the world.
Is that true?
How many time zones are there that it would always be 5 a.m?
We got my gun.
Wait, how do I...
Wasn't there a way to be able to switch weapons?
Hold on.
We're getting back into it.
I guess I have to pick them up, don't I?
Okay, never mind.
Let's read this again.
I'm pretty sure I read it before, but...
Hmm.
There's like 26 some places have half hour...
Half hour times?
Differences?
That's crazy, though.
Half hour?
Wait, that's so confusing.
is Luna diggers and other large mining equipment for
excavation.
Mining zones are assigned each morning for your safety
remain within the approved areas at all time.
Okay.
Oh yeah, and then the Luna digger has gone berserk!
I saw it with my own two eyes.
Is this the way we're supposed to go?
What is this?
Oh, impact bear.
Which is that?
Okay.
I think this is the way I'm supposed to go, no?
I could have used you.
Where were you?
Don't get excavated, okay?
Don't get excavated.
Why does she sound like a Bart Simpson all of a sudden?
Okay.
A-Oh, oh, wait, what is the scan button?
Nope, that's, uh, this one?
Oh, that's shoot.
Let's aim.
What is scanning?
It's not LB.
It's not L1.
R1 was shoot.
Ah!
No, it's not!
He's coming this way!
Wait!
I'm so...
You guys, I'm screwed.
Income.
Oh, I'm screwed.
I'm screwed.
Can I get in here?
Wait, wait.
Oh, uh...
Thanks to you.
Get to those buildings!
Easy for you to save.
What buildings?
What building?
Oh my gosh.
Am I...
Am I just having to run?
Am I almost dead?
No, we made it!
We're fine!
We made it!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
That's okay, though.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my god, that was craziness!
Oh, thank goodness.
Wait, are those robots still coming after me?
I don't know what else I was supposed to do there.
I definitely think I messed that up, though.
Alt for morale.
The prompt showed up, and I just wanted to press the
buttons.
Well, goodness.
I still don't know how to scan.
Sorry about that, but...
I should have known!
That R1 was not it.
Oh, all my parkoring could have led me Look at all of that
that we could have done.
I'm on, I'm controller.
Yeah, maybe, let's see what my controls are.
I don't know why I can't remember how to.
I don't know why I can't remember how to do it.
Oh, controls.
Hmm.
Oh, there is, I do have the...
What was run?
Oh, it's X!
Is that a person?
No, it's a robot.
Look at this thing!
How the heck am I supposed to get around him?
Wait a second.
I'm, like, actually trapped.
Um, wait, is that...
I wish I could zoom.
Do you think I could go up there, maybe?
Maybe.
And that looks like a mine.
I'm pretty sure?
If I decoy octopus.
Oh, whoops.
How long will he be decoyed for?
How long will he feel like he needs to attack me?
But I want this back, too.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Oh, and the barrier goes upwind.
Oh my gosh, jump!
Thank you.
Ah!
From where?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Okay, good.
We avoided.
We managed to avoid.
Drowning?
Uh...
Yeah!
Okay, good.
Yeah?
You want some of this?
Yeah, stupid.
Okay, we're getting back into it, guys.
I can't hack them yet.
It's fine.
We'll get them just like this.
Look out.
Great gameplay, everybody.
Hayak!
Hockey dokey!
I wish I could grab that.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay, good.
We made it.
Wait a minute, what was that?
Oh, another guy.
Oh, okay.
I haven't lost my touch even a little bit.
Don't worry.
You can
definitely reach that orange cube.
You think so?
Let's try it.
Wait, what's down there?
Wait, oh, but if I go in there, then I have to go back up.
How sad.
I don't know.
Can I get this guy too?
Maybe from here my hacking is my range is so sad.
Never mind.
Run and jump.
From here?
Oh shoot.
Oh.
Bad news.
Bad news for us.
We're fine?
Okay, hold on.
Hey!
Oh, okay, he's just going in a circle.
We made it!
Let's go?
Okay, maybe the decoy would have been so much better here,
huh?
Or, like, rather than the thing that I got.
We missed so much stuff.
That's okay, though.
That's a-okay.
That's just gotta- gotta how it has to be.
Okay.
I knew you could do it, gamer.
Thank you very much.
What was down here, anyway?
A box.
Alright, what are we doing?
We're going to this special box?
And we will- We are not falling.
Okay.
inching over this is like the ration and middle gear oh my
god we got digital dominance increases hacking damage by 10%
but weapon damage decreases you use that if you want to
prioritize hacking my hacking build where am I supposed to
go she showed me the way and I'm wait Diana I think I'm
lost.
Dana, where's the door?
Oh, wait, is that it right there?
What?
She actually gave a build tip.
I know, and she's so good.
Where's the door?
Am I...
Oh, wait.
I think it's up there.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I see it.
I see...
I think, like, right above my head.
Pretty sure that's it.
Wait, what?
Wait, it's to my left.
Is it?
I'm actually so confused.
There's a checkpoint in there?
But where am I supposed to go?
Diana, help!
I'm lost!
Do I...
I don't think I can go that way.
I don't think that doesn't look correct.
But that thing looks I don't know.
From up there, maybe?
Where's the blinking red light?
The fans?
Mark, welcome to a membership.
Thank you!
Behind the debris.
Okay, okay, okay.
The pot.
Behind the debris.
Got it.
I wonder if I can get back to over there.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, maybe we can do a decoy on the other side and lure
him, lure the worm over there and then we go to the debris?
We need to drop the yellow box.
Oh, I see the red light!
Okay, I see it now.
I see it now.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Got it.
Okay.
That's okay.
Alright, we're gonna go back to the...
This might be a mistake.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay, okay.
I see it.
Um.
We'll do.
Wait, how do I get up there?
Wait, did I need...
I didn't need to jump from...
No, there's no way I would have made it.
How do I get up there?
I see two...
I see a red robot there, too.
Wait, actually, how do I get...
I guess...
Okay.
My teeny brain today is not processing anything.
Too hard to it!
Happy birthday!
Of course!
My, my, it's birthday delicious!
Yes!
Can I... I guess I should probably trying i don't know how
to get anywhere holy cow i'm so lost i'm so stinking lost
okay i need gamer paint like stat
i wonder what the are those red things are those mines you
know what if i die i die
Grub.
What is this?
Oh.
What is happening?
Incoming.
Projectiles incoming.
Oh my god.
I'm just running around at this point.
Wait, I wonder if I can hack it from down here right oh oh
oh shoot
i keep it in the wrong ways i regret everything oh my god i
have one hp 131 hp in a dream i don't think we're gonna make
it wait i couldn't reach it though i tried to get it maybe i
have to to get rid of that thing first.
Oh, that guy is coming at me again, though.
Stay away from those dust clouds.
He's coming.
Slowly but surely.
Well, at least we can take care of this thing first.
Oh, that's right.
I do have heals.
I forgot I had those.
Thank you guys.
Okay.
Um, now I wasted my decoy.
Let's see.
Am I going to be able to
get...
Oh, we're so dead.
What the hell?
I'm sorry, I didn't get to read your super chat, but thank
you.
Thanks to you.
I'm so...
I feel like an idiot for real, though.
Wait, can I?
Be careful!
Get in on this side?
Oh, we're just like in the impact zone.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna climb.
Um.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, you're supposed to go in.
You're supposed to go in.
Wait, Bede?
Maybe I can heal again.
Okay, I forgot about me.
It doesn't care.
It's stupid.
I can get it.
No!
There we go.
Holy cow.
Whatever.
Whatever works works.
Wait.
Wow.
I hate those things.
That thing was so annoying.
That's okay.
Somehow we made it through.
Um, I don't think that was, I don't think that's how I was
supposed to go, but, um, I did it anyway.
I did it anyway.
Okay.
Well, we make it work.
Yeah, if it works, it works.
Why not?
Where is my button?
There it is.
If it's stupid and it works, it's not stupid.
Thank you for validating me.
Wait, can I?
Let's go home.
Let's go get our heels back.
Check it out.
Let's go get our heels.
Let's go heal real quick.
That was good.
There's a few planned ways.
We made it work.
Yes, give me it all.
Tell me when it's go time, okay?
Okay.
And then also...
We can...
Do I do my suit?
No, I think hacking should be our priority.
We'll hack.
Hack upgrade.
She is so cute, isn't she?
Everybody is cat.
Exactly how I like it.
We'll save up.
Okie dokie.
Oh, that's...
Oh, we got a couple mods.
Successfully activating EC thrusters restore 10% of HP.
Oh, that's kind of nice.
When HP is full, attack power increases by 10%.
And then the last one, which I won't do.
Wait, what do I have with...
clip right now.
10% more Luna filament.
Enemy stay open longer.
That's pretty good.
Hacking range.
That's what I want to.
Hi, Amido.
I hope you're cat.
I mean, well.
I am cat.
Main kitty.
Everybody is cat.
It's true.
Increases the use speed of repair cartridges and boost their
effect.
I think this is still good, though.
I think what we have is good.
Oh wait, I have an extra hacking node!
We can equip multi-hack!
What do I have here?
Gunfire or passing through heat nodes...
What do I have now?
Passing through offensive nodes where gunfire will increase
the damage on the next hack.
Gunfire or passing through heat nodes boost the heat gauge.
Heat gauge!
Making it easier to overheat enemies.
Let's do that one.
Okay.
Back to where we were.
Yes, warehouse entrance.
Okay.
Hmm.
The warehouse.
Your mom's house.
Oh, I thought that was a person real quick.
No, it's right there taunting me!
It's right there taunting me!
So mean?
Move.
Oh.
Okay, so this is locked.
Oh, this is a red zone.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Okay, just kidding.
I forgot what they looked like.
I feel like we're gonna get jump scared by like a guy right
there or something.
Oh!
Kind of puzzly area, this is fun.
Oh.
New.
Yeah.
Gamers don't look up.
Locked.
I'm gonna get it from this side.
Move.
We got a bug net!
This small and lightweight net is easy to swing around to
safely catch insects and other skittering critters, but it's
actually unusually hard to rip.
I wonder what that is.
You will know.
You will know bug.
Is it?
Okay, yeah, so then we have to go to this side and move it
from here.
Is there somebody in there?
That awfully looks like a little corridor for somebody to be
hiding.
You won't jump scare me?
What?
Oh, I think we're...
Hacking though that makes enemies overheat more easily.
While active weapons build heat gauge faster.
Repeated use on same energy?
Sorry, I can't read it all.
reduces its effectiveness okay okay he bots up enough and
they'll shut down
there are oh this guy oh wait
oh he does twice good to know yeah over heat over heat
Always have... Oh, dang it!
Oh, shoot!
No!
Holy cow!
I got greedy, but it was worth it.
It worked in my favor?
I was greedy, but...
I was never punished.
Yeah.
Oh.
And then...
Oh, uh, RT.
Yeah.
You are...
Oh.
Always greedy!
Yeah, sometimes.
Sometimes, but...
It worked in my fever now, didn't it?
Yeah.
What do I have?
Freeze.
I like a multi-hack, though.
Oh, there's a thing here.
Can I open this?
No, only on the other side.
sight look at all these containers yeah they're all filled
with limb the material inside seems fresh nothing refined
like lunatic elements figures more moon dirt can i go get
that i was hoping we could take some back to the shelter my
moon dirt wait is that right here
I think I locked us out.
I think I messed it up.
Alright, let's move this guy.
This is the most bizarre game of Tetris.
What's that up there?
Ah, gamers don't look up, everybody.
walk puzzle.
Is it really a puzzle?
I want to get to that.
I want that.
I moved it, but I... Oh, I see what I did!
Oh!
I see it now.
Oops.
Wait, can I still move it?
Wait, then I think I can get it.
Right?
Maybe?
Perhaps?
Maybe.
Yes!
I didn't realize it could be moved again.
Okay, now we locked ourselves.
We locked ourselves in.
I hear you say gamers don't look up in my head every time I
check the ceiling.
I think you're obsessed with me.
Oh!
You hearing my voice?
in your head.
Yellow zone.
I don't want to be peed on.
Homing missiles.
What are you trying to tell me?
Use the homing missile.
Oh, I forgot about my shockwave gun.
Yeah, let's use that.
Use the homing missile.
What is this thing?
What is this?
Oh, printer!
Use the sticky bombs!
Oh, oh.
Isis!
Oh my gosh.
Oh
shoot!
Ah!
Point!
Oh, uh...
Oh!
I didn't realize that guy was still alive!
Where are you?
Oh yeah.
Oh shit!
Oh my gosh, I'm almost dead.
Again.
Oh!
RT!
Daughter on board.
There's gonna be more though, right?
It's not over.
Yeah, it's not over.
My homing missiles?
Oh!
Me too!
uh where where is my oh shoot uh what others look how far
it's targeting
can i how do i get to it though charge piercer do i shoot at
it uh wait is it like the other thing where i have to oh
shoot the floating round thing that's Shoot the shoulder.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
It's like, it's similar to the other thing.
I remember.
I'm gonna make another impact barrier.
Ouch.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, I remember this.
That other thing is the same way.
Uh...
Homeing missile!
I'm breaking the enemy.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Nice.
We got him.
And one more.
No worries.
Easy peasy.
See?
I used it just as it told me to.
Overkill.
Nice.
Okay.
And then we can grab more.
things again.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, the impact barrier is like actually insane.
It's kind of crazy.
What's this go to?
I told my work I'm going to a family friend's birthday on
Saturday and I'm going to family!
You will cover for me, right?
I hope you're doing well.
Taco!
Have fun!
See you then!
Yeah, of course, family friend's birthday.
It's my birthday.
We're celebrating.
Alright.
We're celebrating you.
Was there anything back here?
Or am I crazy?
There was nothing back here.
Am I crazy?
Can I take this?
Oh, charge piercer.
Can I update him because hacking gauge is full?
I didn't realize.
And yes, I did see that door open up.
Over there.
Why'd you do that?
Okay, good.
The cube.
Oh, you're loon!
Nice.
Confused.
that.
Okay, we got more like, this is the printer, right?
Yeah.
Let's print a gun.
Nice.
Re-Rumors about Dr. Higgins.
To Ariel, from Herman.
Is it true Dr. Higgins brought his daughter's biometric data
into the lab?
daughter Daisy stayed on earth when he moved to the moon but
I wonder why he'd bring her data here maybe for Luna
filament research either way he's throwing everything into
this project if it works the results won't just be
impressive they'll be historic oh no she is the doctor had a
daughter Daisy that name ring a bell I think when I got the
stop code from eight I also got some data from her memory.
Dr. Higgins made us both to help with his research.
So he's the one that created Pragmeta.
Mm-hmm.
Daisy, Daisy, give me your answer, too.
Oh.
No, we can make this move.
Oh, there it is.
I'm half crazy.
Over my love for you.
It's so Astro Boy.
Astro Boy.
Wait.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
My bad.
I want to get that, but I don't know if I can.
There's a thing all over.
the way up there even did you see that wait holy cow there's
stuff everywhere here we go now we're exploring now we're
exploring wait please please like look there's a crate all
the way up there this part hurt my brain to get it there's
also I don't think we can go in there but who knows this
opened up what did it maybe oh I thought it was a door like
everything I thought this was like the way I was supposed to
go but okay in that room is the way I'm supposed to go got
it we're exploring a little bit but I'm lost
yeah that's why I was like oh I have to um
I have to go through all this other stuff first before I go
downstairs but this part of me going pushing so many boxes
is it what I was gonna say is it possible is it is it doable
got it it's got to be oh wait
is it possible is it true someone can do that wait I don't
want to I I think it moves back over there, which I don't
want to do.
Oh, to the blue lines!
Oh, yeah, baby.
Everything is pasta-able.
Pasta.
I tried the new pasta.
Nice.
I tried a new pasta place recently.
And it was like...
I was so excited about it.
I got like...
raving reviews about it and i was like oh my gosh this is
gonna be the pasta of all time and it was okay i was like oh
man my pasta that's just okay can i go down here oh i see
mid pasta yeah oh i didn't even realize when was there wait
this is locked Can I get it from here?
Come on.
I'm in the air.
Come on!
Wait, maybe I could do it from this side?
Wait, is this a hole?
Yes.
Okay.
It's fine, exploring is fine.
We make it a go.
What makes a pasta really great is the sauce.
The thing is, is it was like...
Like the, what's it called?
The, um...
Like the taste, not the taste of the noodles, but like the
noodle consistency was strange.
Does that make sense?
Yay, we did it!
That was so easy.
Nice!
Nodes!
Increases hacking node drop rate from enemies by 10%.
That guy.
Alright, now we'll go onwards.
Wait.
ABS?
It says, like, many meters away.
How am I so close to this one?
It's underneath here.
Hmm.
strange yeah I don't know like you know like when pasta
noodles are kind of like they have like a sandy texture it
was kind of like that is
this a door no oh my own reflection scared me
I don't think they were undercooked because I weren't like
hard
area three limb generated area Where are you?
Where are we?
We're still moving boxes.
Oh, that guy's like hard at work.
Hard at work or hardly working.
Am I right?
I hear a lot going on actually.
What is that sound?
Oh,
oh, wait.
It won't let me.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm letting it get away.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Uh, wait, why can't I hack it?
I think it's getting away.
Don't let it get away!
I messed up.
Oh well.
Don't let it get away!
Immediately lets it get away.
My bad.
Oh wait, I need to send this thing back so I can go get the
box up there.
Spin?
Then it...
Then it dies.
Such is the life.
Wait!
I was mid-hacking you, mister.
How you like this?
How you like that?
Guy is just trying to do his job.
Couldn't catch a single one in my playthrough.
That's okay.
Don't even sweat it.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
What do we got here?
We've got...
Four cubes!
That's huge!
Nice going.
Wait, actually I want to push this back again.
Four whole cubes.
Four golden cubes!
I've got the high ground now.
Anybody else?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Good job.
Good job, Hugh.
The pasta place I go to does these fried mac and cheese.
Four more cubes.
Mac and cheese balls are calamari.
The ham, hawk, and pancetta pasta.
Oh, sorry.
Carbonara is also so good.
If I hadn't just eaten, I'd totally get some right now.
Amazing.
Mac and cheese balls?
Sign me up.
I think we have, yeah, we have two heats already.
Oh my gosh.
Am I getting it?
I hope though.
There we go.
Uh, I can kind of get it.
I'm not doing a very good job!
Ouch, Ouch.
You know what?
That's fine.
Ouch!
Wait, no!
I wanted to RT him!
Here we go, we can do it now.
Okay, now let's get away from this guy.
Uh, yeah.
Be careful!
Oh, whoops.
Run!
And...
Drink this.
Nice.
Oh, thank goodness.
I got my shockwave gun back.
I should have known from this giant...
They're pretty good about, like, keeping it on your toes.
Sometimes you see things like that, and it's just part of
the atmosphere.
It, like, fits...
It blends right in.
You would never know that it's about to be your worst.
Nightmare?
Hmm.
Photon laser.
Ah, cute.
Ah, there we go.
Is this...
Oh no, that's a...
Tuna?
Behind me.
Where is he?
I also like hear voices.
It's like people talk...
Hello, Crinkle?
I'm assuming I have to go down, but I'm very afraid to at
the same time.
I'm very, I'm quite afraid too.
I'm afraid of the ambush, but we must go.
Let's go.
Let me heal real quick.
That should be good.
Okay.
floors are lava it says caution right it's gotta be oh maybe
not okay this is a actual puzzle more containers with panels
this seems like your kind of thing why I mean it's all
hacking and puzzles and stuff right no no matrix code
conversion isn't a puzzle I have to analyze and then
substantiate the Okay, okay, I get it.
She's a nerd, you guys.
Oh, my daughter is a nerd.
Happy post-birthday.
Oh, yeah!
It was Tuna's birthday!
Tuna!
She's speaking jargon.
Loser jargon and stuff.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh, that pushed it quite far, much further than I thought it
would.
Hmm.
Oh, nice.
I don't know if that does anything.
Oh, maybe we can... I don't know.
Oh, nice!
Okay!
Very good!
Yay!
Wait, where is he?
How do I get up there?
I think I messed up.
Where is he?
It's like one of the first ones I feel like I haven't been
able to find.
He's like over there.
Maybe he is where we haven't gone yet.
Maybe I have to go him over here.
Oh!
It's a cabin!
What's wrong with you?
No!
More training data.
There he is!
Oh my god, imagine if I like absolutely blasted him.
Well done.
How can I get over there though?
I don't know with my current setup if I can.
Maybe.
Nice shot, thank you.
Nice.
Me too.
Let's do some upgrades.
The top floor, maybe.
Maybe?
Maybe.
Okay.
Upgrade time.
And we gotta give her...
Okay.
Her new bug catching set.
I love it when we can bring stuff back with us.
She's so cute.
That was a lot of container moving.
Yeah, it was.
Wow, that's a big hill for lots of bugs.
Yippee!
I'll catch butterflies, birds, and maybe even a cat.
You're gonna catch a bird?
With that?
Yeah?
I'm right behind you.
That's like...
There's like a million bugs in there.
Maybe even a cat.
All those containers wasted on piles of dirt.
Pretty strange, huh?
I wonder where all the refined Luna filament got to.
Maybe Edis is using it to make more bots.
Oh.
You're probably right.
It doesn't make any sense that it would disappear like that.
We gotta knock some sense into Edis before it burns things.
through it all yeah talk about bad timing you step out of
the vault and into this miss hi I'm having fun I may not
remember anything before the vault but this has to be the
most fun I've ever had we get to go so many places she is so
smart right oh yeah I have a question about that globe
there's all these lines all over it isn't that annoying for
the people who live actually those lines aren't really there
they're just boundaries between countries humans have spent
centuries making has anyone did anyone else think that that
the globe actually like the actual earth had the same lines
I think the one we just got was oh I think the football
player it's a classic kid thing it really does feel like a
classic kid like thought right let's see I We can do...
Oh man, I wish we could upgrade all three, but we can't.
Do we want to keep them even or...
I think we got to do more damage.
I use my grip gun so much.
Oh, reliable.
I think even more hacking.
But also, things are getting tougher.
Maybe I should do my defense and my HP.
It's not by much though.
Hmm.
I thought that until I had a family vacation out of state.
You're like, what?
Yeah, I think that was so too.
That was me.
Like, we went for vacation and I was like, where?
Where's the dividers?
Oh yeah, I also used to spin the globe and stop on whatever
country.
I thought the equator used to be there.
Me too!
Yes!
It's like the equator.
The big line dividing the earth.
best defense is good offense you are so right honestly i
think like open duration is so important but also a heat
gauge build up is so good too i gotta use the ult more when
i when i need to and hacking damage is also more like the
hacking is so op it's so good
hacking.
And then next, we'll do my suit.
What do we have new here?
Unit schematic registry updated.
For what?
We have 2000.
Nice.
I want to do my shockwave gun.
I really like this thing.
I wish it had more ammo capacity.
Combust hack module.
Oh, the combust I have it maxed out.
Multi-hack maybe would be good too.
I know.
I feel stunning enemies is quite good too.
Not auto-hack.
We could do more mod slot.
My thruster!
Okay, wait.
We have...
I can't do both.
I can either do repair or my thrusters.
I think my repair.
No!
Yeah, multi-hacking is really good.
I like using it.
Overdrive.
I'll do my thrusters.
And then we'll do repair next time.
Just don't get hit, dummy.
Just don't get hit.
Oh, overdrive.
Alright.
Nice.
Nodes.
We'll just leave that as it is.
My loadout.
We have a shockwave gun.
Charge.
Let's not do charge.
Let's do the homing missiles.
Those are pretty good.
Oh, wait.
And then.
Grip gun.
Yeah.
What else we got here?
Oh yeah, that's right!
I forgot we like got this thing too.
But no, we'll keep to our grip gun.
Stasis net?
Yeah, that's fine.
I forgot about this one.
And then Decoy Generator.
No.
Back to Impact Barrier.
Good to know I'm not alone in singing Overdrive.
Never alone!
I was like, when did you become Mint Paintum?
Not the suppository song.
It is.
Okay, Iki-mas!
Warehouse exit.
The music in this game is so good.
I want...
I want OST so bad.
Yahoo!
Where did I come from?
Down here?
Nah.
I was like, maybe, maybe I could find a way.
We're going back outside!
Oh, man.
Oh.
No more boxes.
No, I liked the boxes.
Mining rig to get across.
That thing.
Why would you rather be out here than just doing boxes?
I'm sorry.
What the heck?
Reboot Edis.
Use the mining rig to get across.
Why are there so many boxes here?
Oh.
Hugh loves the worm.
Yeah.
Maybe sticky bombs would be...
If we're about to fight the worm, maybe sticky bombs would
be better.
Maybe.
This looks like a boss area for real, for real.
We're gonna try and do the thing.
And then he's gonna be like...
No.
You can't.
Whoa!
Oh wait, we're finally...
Wait, is this where we've been trying to get to?
No, we've been trying to get to...
Here!
Wait.
Whoa.
Very good.
Of course, of course.
Oh my god!
It's a hole!
Oh, okay.
He just dropped them.
Phew!
Ah!
A bunch of bots over here too.
Yeah.
Friendly fire!
Yeah, I know.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
I got greedy.
Dang, they hit hard.
He got him though.
He's got him.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Check.
Take this!
Are you back to normal?
Don't do that.
It's not it, is it?
Take that?
Um...
Oh, okay.
That's so fine.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Jump?
Okay.
Ouch!
Oh, come on.
That was so mean!
Ah!
Okay, she could have done that, but that's okay.
You're just shooting the beach.
Oh.
She could have hacked those, but that's okay.
Okay, good, good, good.
You made it?
Oh!
What was that?
Oh, my gosh, please.
Um, sticky bombs?
Wait, what the heck is that, man?
Wait, is there a homing thing here?
Oh, also, let's do that.
Where'd he go?
Wait a second.
They really want me to use the charge pier somehow.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Can I?
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
You're oversized, honk, or junk!
Oh shoot, I think I missed.
Oh!
Ah!
That was close!
Wait, there's a second one!
I got it.
We're in like phase two.
Phase, phase 50?
We're in phase 50?
Uh...
Yeah, we got him.
Come here?
Yeah.
That was close.
She says tanking both hits.
I know!
I only took one hit!
I think I had iframes for the second one.
Where am I shooting even?
I don't even know what I'm shooting.
What are these?
Where are those coming?
What am I looking out for?
Ooh!
Spicy.
Come back, I'm gonna kill you now.
Take this!
Yeah!
Stupid head.
Give me all my money.
Stace is not...
Riot Blaster.
Oh, Choco I have a gun.
We made it.
Easy peasy.
That Rick was kind of fun.
Fun?
We were almost torn to pieces.
That is true.
No way.
They're like, hey, buddy, that one was tough.
Here's another ladder.
I mean, I don't see why not.
What?
Just so I can get my health back.
Diana had fun.
I'm glad for her.
Buddy.
You went through it.
Here, take this ladder.
Safe and snug.
What's the exclamation point?
Oh, I forgot it was hide and seek.
She is...
oh that was so fast wow you you're so good at this you won't
find me next time i'll pick oh yeah bad thing she's my
little adhd daughter the bugs and cars and shoes whose shoes
are those definitely not hers I saw when the kitty could
just pop out of nowhere that's so true I can catch one next
time you better think twice before swinging a net her face
when she says that her face when she said that was just so
like you never know when a kitty cat is gonna pop up you
have to have your net so just be Patient and see if they'll
come around Recently I saw shoes that were like so I think
they belong to a giant for real I was like there's no way
anybody could have a shoe size this This big oh, I forgot I
have a cabin coins New training suit data has arrived.
Thank you We'll be here.
Oh, oops If you need us I think they were like size 30
centimeters Be sure to give it a try What is that in U.S.
sizing, actually?
I don't know.
U.S.
Wait, 30 centimeter shoes to U.S.
size.
The men's?
13?
Is that normal?
Is that a normal size?
It's not too excessive.
Wait, maybe it was bigger.
Wait, because I remember...
No, I think it was like...
Hold on.
I remember thinking, oh my gosh, that's almost like...
That's almost...
That's like...
Because I'm...
24.
Sorry, I'm thinking of like Japanese shoe sizes.
I'm a size 12?
13 is the biggest size you can easily find.
I wear like a US women's size Four and a half, five,
depending on the shoe.
And then...
I think I was 24.
Yeah, I can wear kids' shoes if I want.
Sometimes they're cuter.
But I remember because Vicky was just like...
She was like, I didn't know that size existed.
Let's see, we could get this outfit, or we could get the red
key.
I don't think I'll do any, like, red gate stuff.
Oh, assembler, Bob!
We got more Bingo!
Bingo!
Wait, we're gonna get another bingo.
Bought data.
How boring!
To provide one of our greatest goods.
Thank you!
Please enjoy your
We weren't shoe shopping, but we had to, we had to give our
shoe size for, for something.
Reassembler.
Oh.
I like how, this guy is so cool looking.
The bots are like, like, this is a, this is a working bot,
but he is so menacing looking for no reason.
Okay, let's go back to game.
My hacking node.
Okay, shockwave, and we'll do the homing missiles again.
I would think that's a great combo, honestly.
Actually, can I upgrade my homing missiles?
What's she doing?
Oh, she's making a flower crown!
Um, homing missiles.
Yeah, we should up our damage on this.
charge speed.
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
And for our hacking nodes, we got...
We got a lot of heat.
We'll do...
Confuse is great.
And we'll do...
What's the code doing it?
Oh, temporarily increased.
Oh yeah, that's right.
If I...
through it and shoot it it does it damage better better
bigger better okay we're good to go mining control rover
freeze is good too yeah if we if we find it I can pick it up
but yeah master me like I am master master Miller lucky oh
back outside already I want but it's ground the worm the
worm
okay so far so wormless.
The worm!
Liquid minto.
I can see I can jump up over there.
I'm invisible walled right now.
Oh, okay.
I'm invisible walled again.
We are definitely incoming a worm attack.
Come on.
Got it!
Whoa, what's that do?
Hello?
Any worker bots?
Oh,
we can go in now, right?
Remember, do not do this down on earth.
Do what?
Yeah, do what?
Sneaking into places we aren't supposed to be.
But it's fine.
That is a lot of limb.
Nice.
I need a lot of limb.
and we got eagle eye increases attack power by 15% while
airborne okay that will make you hit harder while in low
gravity okay that looks like a trap though no that looks
like a trap I wonder if we could keep going up like I
move those boxes maybe not maybe i do need to go inside wait
but there's stuff all the way over there too surely that
does not look like a wormhole that's not a hole where a worm
would come out oh
oh there's some earth data in there
yeah let me in Oh, we're already depressurizing everything.
Oh, this is spooky.
Oh, it's, we're in like real spooky hours now.
Yes, this is a lab, or at least it was.
Maybe the lunaticer did this.
Lab incident and cause.
Pass through the ruins.
This is Vishwanath.
from the medical advancement lab i'm writing regarding
employee noah parker who was recently admitted to the
medical bureau upon transfer his right forearm had been
compromised by a black fibrous substance that's right this
stuff is taken over the damage has since progressed to his
upper arm and he is currently in critical condition the
wishy-wash wishy-wash furthermore the substance responsible
remains on the unidentified it exhibits extremely potent
dissolving effects on organic matter and grows by absorbing
the material it contacts given its probable lunar origin we
hypothesize it may be related to lunum like a lunum
poisoning or something any insights you could provide from a
direct examination would be greatly appreciated it swallows
things and then grows it can't be as dangerous as it sounds
Okay.
Hew!
Hew?
Okay, it's spooky in here for real though.
Hew mongus.
I'm scared.
We're passing through the ruins.
What about all the stuff outside though?
For real.
Am I crazy for having not tried to go get it?
Should I try to go get it?
Should I go back?
What's all this?
What's that?
Look like an egg.
What the?
Oh, okay.
Stop skittering around!
Ouch!
Get ready!
Leave the shooting to me.
Or not.
Oh, that was close.
Get off!
Where'd he go?
There we go.
Oh, there he is.
We're supposed to get all overheated and stuff.
There we go.
These tiny guys are annoying.
Oh, okay.
That's...
I thought I was supposed to go up.
But I'm supposed to go through this door that was locked
previously.
Makes sense.
Let's go attempt the outdoors.
Maybe?
Will it let me?
I feel like I'm gonna get wormed!
Oh gosh, that scared me for a second.
I think we're getting pretty close.
You can see the earth so well from here.
You can?
Yep.
Nice and clear shot at all.
Wait, where are you guys seeing that?
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
Oh, okay, okay.
It is safe!
Everybody you learn from me.
You can learn...
Wow!
Let's go collect some more things.
It's safe!
But it pays to be paranoid.
It still pays to be paranoid.
I say.
The circle.
I know, I know.
I also want to get this over here.
Because it was technically outside, I believe.
So we have to jump up through here.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, a tent!
A lightweight portable tent set.
Too simple for serious camping, but perfect for a kid's
secret hideout.
Nice.
I can't wait to get back to the shelter.
The music sounded like the song from that Radwim's song.
It's like, Na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na
na na na na na na na na na Yeah, we're about to be Yudu
camping for real.
Okay
Hoi Hoi.
All right.
Let's check this out always looks so blue down there every
place has its own kind of color you know everything about
the earth don't you everything I've always been into this
space stargazing I've been all over searching for places
with the best views and clear skies went all the way to the
Namib desert once Namib is that unusual maybe a bit
adventurous for some She looks so dirty all of a sudden,
because of the graphics.
Why did the graphics look like this all...
Thanks, Master Chief.
I want to go too.
Go where?
To all the places you've been.
All of them?
Yeah, all of them.
Is that so?
Then let's do it.
Let's do it!
Oh!
Me and Diane are the same.
Wait, there's a...
There's a cube up there.
We gotta get it.
Wait, is this a printer?
I missed it completely.
What can we print?
Church piercer or stasis net?
Let's do it!
The flags.
I know the flags are waving.
The flags are flagging.
The flags do be flying.
They're flying high.
Where was it?
I saw it from in here, so maybe it's up here?
Where did I see it from?
I saw it from the window out there.
I know what I saw.
I know I saw a cube.
scan.
There it is.
Is there a dog in here?
It's up there!
How do I?
How?
Hold on.
Let's check in here real quick.
It seems more likely...
No.
I'm just gonna save from up there, but...
I don't know.
I give up.
Anyway.
Let's go.
Maybe a loopback.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, a goop.
Uh-oh.
Don't touch it.
Ooh, it sounds so icky.
Eee!
It sounds so, like, static-y, like, radioactive.
Radioactive.
oh there's a guy there i see him he's just doing his job how
is he not infected
it's a cutscene what the heck is that thing you say you're
one of the no walker
oh oh my gosh there's one to one Oh, I can't, I can't step
in it either.
Holy cow.
Spooky!
Oh my gosh, now we're gonna have to be fighting walkers that
are...
I'm not so sure.
I think it's that black stuff that's doing this.
Yeah.
First Edis, now mysterious black goop.
Mysterious black goop?
Oh.
I don't think that's good, you guys.
Do you think I can get it from here?
Let's see.
Oh, I got it.
I made it.
Hear me out.
That robot would.
I'm kind of a believer of any robot.
So yeah, I agree.
I get it.
Yeah, I get it.
What's going on here?
Good morning, FYI, routine inspections and access log audits
will begin shortly at the Nexus Tower.
Please note that internal communications within the tower
will be offline, so responses may be delayed during this
period.
For- oh, whoops.
I wanted to read the forward, forward, forward, forward.
Great.
Now that ticket I scored for Galactica Metal's final world
tour is wasted.
arena seats.
I'll never get this chance again.
No, a VR stream just can't match the real thing.
No, don't tell me.
The station AI is scanning my thoughts?
Can't even daydream about my favorite band in peace?
I should have never come to the moon.
It's scanning your thoughts?
I would be so in trouble.
Oh, that would be... Oh, it would be... It would be over for
me.
Oh, we got a red gate key.
Okay.
Red zone.
Here we come.
Not today.
What was that?
Oh.
You get a chance to look at the files.
Ah, right.
You mean that one about a mysterious substance that
dissolves organic matter.
Yeah, yeah.
Straight to moon jail.
That would be me.
what years they wouldn't hide to me that serious now would
they but there's always the possibility we could be working
i wouldn't worry about it anyway isn't it time to change
shifts yeah no all right now i gotta drop by the nexus tower
i had to work have a good day at work thank you oh so they
didn't take the group seriously
listen no i don't care about that.
Was there anything down here?
I don't think so.
Oh wait.
There's, oh there is some goop.
There's some goop and gobbles.
All right.
Can't, I don't think I can dissolve the red goop yet though.
No, I'm not a red goopster.
Only normal goop.
I will take a data shard though.
Very nice.
everybody why were there jumpsuits on the floor maybe they
all went goop crazy and took off their clothes like it's
kind of like a hypothermia you know when people go naked on
Mount Everest could be
packed barrier stasis net okay what are we about to face
what are we about to face I'll open this up, but I don't
think I need to go back.
Should we take a break?
What do we have?
Oh, we have three extra upgrade components.
Oh, we could upgrade.
Um...
And we have the Earth memory.
Yeah, the tent.
Okay, we'll go add the tent.
We'll go add our tent.
No, I don't mean it is hypothermia, just like, you know, how
you get really warm when you you are hypothermic.
Is that the right word?
Hypothermic.
When you get high, when you have hypothermia, you take off
your clothes.
What if it's the same?
When you get gooped, you take off your clothes.
I'm missing four HP.
Oh, thank God we came back.
Thank goodness.
I said I was gonna do my suit.
Okay.
Next time we'll do hacking again.
Paradoxal undressing.
Air Raiders really zoom out fast, huh?
Yeah, the goop gets all over you and you feel like you have
to get it off by taking your clothes off.
I wish I could fly.
You probably could.
You flap your lips enough.
If you're gonna gab, then stay down here on your own two
feet.
Yeah.
I guess that makes sense.
No, it doesn't.
Plus, if I flew away, we wouldn't be able to talk.
That'd be bad.
Two years are freaking it.
Thank you so much, Vextamator.
Thank you!
Turns out there are not many cat bots on the moon.
I know, but there should be.
There should be.
Did you know animal bots can function on the moon?
Just like me?
Are you for real?
Talk about a waste of R&D.
No, it's not.
Cats walking on the moon would be cute.
But they probably don't want to walk around here why not I
think cats wait what do you mean a waste though I thought he
meant a waste of R&D that they're not making more cats
didn't you have any human friends hanging around here at the
cradle I'm not sure I don't remember maybe if I did have a
friend I wouldn't have ended up in the vault you're cooking
up a drawing of Diana's outfit and I'm sure you'll meet a
important part is to get naked mid-factor pop maybe a few
you won't
Wait, no, no, wait, Diana, Diana, Diana, Diana.
Pay attention to me.
Diana, Diana.
The balloon's all okay?
Yep, they're all there.
Oh, she's got all her balloons.
What is this angle?
Why are we on the floor?
What's wrong?
Well, the truth is, I did lose one.
That's all part of what makes balloons fun.
Don't sweat it.
Okay, Diana, come here.
I have to give you something.
The tent.
Does that complete this area?
I think?
She's confused.
Read Earth memories.
Yay!
Replicating related objects.
I did it!
Wow!
Oh,
camping is so much fun.
She's going in.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, she's just like a cat.
This is my secret hideout.
Stay out, Hugh.
She really is just like a cat.
Just flopping down.
in there.
It's nice having some quiet time.
What should I do?
No, Diana, we're about to leave, actually.
I'll get a bigger tent someday.
I'll invite you in.
Yeah, no stinky boys.
No boys allowed.
No master chiefs, master cats.
Ducky ducky, I got a cabin coin.
Let's do that.
New training sim data has arrived.
Thank you.
Be sure to give it a try.
Wait, what is that?
What is that big thing under the locked area?
Interesting.
I could get another red gate key or we could get another
outfit or we could start the next one.
What's a blackout do we get?
Another outfit.
Let's do...
Let's do bingo.
Well, that's why I'm so curious what's behind the mysteries.
I want to know what's behind the mysteries!
Oh, that's a bot did.
Lancer bot.
Okay, maximum is a bit of a stretch, but okay.
Wait, let's see.
Lancer bot.
Oh, but this guy had a feeling!
Let's try it out.
This hand is so teeny tiny.
He's got a gut, you notice that?
Lancerbot, your diet though.
Alright.
Shall we go?
I think I still have everything pretty much that I wanted
before, so...
Wait, I got a new mod?
Oh, the eagle eye, that's right.
The dad bod.
Dad bod.
It's just poor posture.
Okay.
Yeah, I get that.
Off the...
Oh, it finally off work.
O2!
Hello?
Thanks for dropping by after work.
Oh, that's right.
That's the net.
Okay, we're rebooting Idus.
We're going back outside.
Oh, that was really fast.
The pressurization process.
Hugh, we can get into the Nexus Tower from over there.
Okay.
Welcome to the Nexus Tower.
Entrance to the tower is strictly prohibited.
Now why?
Any attempt to enter the facility will result in your
immediate termination.
Thanks for the warm welcome.
I'll see myself in.
You can't fire me.
I don't work here.
Oh, that thing.
Okay, we're warming again.
We're warming again.
well let's just see where we can go yeah well then you're
hired and then you're fired okay so we need to get all the
way over there is that a is that a yeah that guy's twitching
then there's a baby look at all these guys holy cow what the
there's dad bot there's everybody's here everybody's here we
came in through this door what's down here not the baby yeah
oh oh come on
could i jump to there what if i jump to there can i get back
up if i couldn't that would be bad news okay well we dropped
this there's another baby oh red-eyed baby okay Okay,
stupid.
Perhaps it's a one-way door.
There's so many guys down here.
There's a guy.
From where?
Oh, that guy.
Oh, that guy is trying to kill me.
Oh, he's looking at me.
Yeah!
Alright.
We needed him to stop being so aggro.
We need him to not see me anymore.
I didn't mean to aggro him.
Was he gonna stop?
Wait, let's do like here.
Oh, shoot.
Never mind.
It can go through walls.
Wait, oh, am I screwed?
Are you done?
Is it out of bullets?
I need him to not be aggroed on me.
Please!
Maybe he's...
He can't see me.
Run and gun, I guess.
Okay, we'll have to...
Projectiles!
Incoming!
This is so stinky!
Probably gotta rush him.
Maybe.
We'll wait until he runs out again, I guess.
If that happens.
He has to run out, right?
Oh my god!
No, Hugh?
Wait, this is so terrible!
I was trying to figure out my route!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Did I get him?
Oh, one hit.
hit nice okay well we took care of that guy that's great um
all right there's a lot going on around here now isn't there
sleepy head can i get back up i could probably oh what is
that a cube and there's a cube there there's cubes all over
hmm Okay, awesome.
Let's go over here.
Oh, I understand now.
I understand what it does.
Oh, okay.
But now I think it opens anytime.
Yes, that's great.
Okay.
Let's see it.
I guess we gotta go the way that we opened up this way.
Okay.
And, uh...
This away?
Yeah.
I see the blue...
The blue gamer.
Gamer paint?
The gamer...
The gamer lines?
Be careful.
I'm trying!
Gamer lines?
Can we get this baby from up here?
That'd be great, no?
Lots of money?
More limb!
Can I turn it down just a tad?
Can I get you?
What?
How do I... I don't know if I can get in, actually.
Stupid.
Nah.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, it would help if I hit.
Oh!
I don't think he knows what he's doing.
I think he's, like, really confused.
He's like, I'm being attacked, but I'm not quite sure how.
He's like really confused.
He definitely knows he's being attacked.
He's just really confused about it.
Oh, come on.
Nope, nope.
Come on.
Come on, baby.
We're so close.
Oh, no.
Come on.
Yeah, when I find you, I'm going to let you have it.
aren't just for monkeying around you know these arms are
well how do I get in there I don't think I could jump over
can I why I had a when I get my hands on you from the stairs
there's stairs down there
There should be stairs underneath.
Okay.
So I gotta be careful of...
Well, I wonder if it'd be safer to drop down from here.
I can't...
No, I think you land on the ground.
We're getting...
gaming?
I'm juking everybody.
Nobody is safe.
It's my turn.
Come on, get his head.
Yeah, we're cheesing them all.
I'm not even gonna, like, waste my hacking nodes on them.
Okay, that's the one guy.
Ah, the guy's guarding the stairs.
Alright.
Perfect.
perfect I'm worried that the worm is gonna give me okay we
made it we made it we made it yes okay
doesn't even notice doesn't even notice wait there's a baby
coming over here.
Don't do that.
No, he's walking away.
Okay, good.
I don't want I don't I need to I don't want to be fighting
both the red guys and the baby and the worm and everybody on
this dang moon.
Can I stand on this?
Yeah.
We're taking our good sweet time.
Hmm.
Okay.
Could be worse.
A red baby worm.
Well, I have overdrive just in case.
Overdrive.
Being graded.
I don't even know what was in there.
I don't know what was in there.
I didn't even see.
Is he, like, closer now?
Am I crazy?
No, he's the same place.
He's like still...
Okay.
It was a cabin coin?
Oh, did I grab it?
I sure hope so.
I sure hope I did.
I think I have to.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared.
Not to.
Yeah, you can call me chicken, but I did it!
Wait, this guy is still down, though.
I could probably get him, too.
Oh my god.
Wait, if I could hit him.
Oh, that was awkward.
Wait a second.
Bravest Minto gameplay?
I did it, though.
Oh,
he might be...
He might really be dumb.
Am I invisible to you people?
Why don't you see me?
Oh my gosh, I keep missing everything.
I'm reloading.
Chat doesn't appreciate tactical stealth action.
Okay, I'm going.
He's not dumb, he's just a slow learner.
Break the antennas, you!
Break the antennas?
What do you mean by that?
What does she mean by that?
I mean, I'm going in, but...
Yay!
Second baby.
Oh, shoot.
Why antennas?
What antennas are we talking about?
Break the antennas.
Oh.
Oh, that didn't do much.
What's she talking about?
The red squares on the face?
Baby?
Sure, to be honest.
Hold on, I'm grabbing the rest of... I'm grabbing your...
Your friends is, uh...
It's so dumb.
Yeah!
Whoa!
I needed to overheat.
She said it even before, like, his...
He was...
Yeah, she wants some antennas broken.
I'm not quite sure what, though.
Holy cow.
What is this?
Yeah, maybe we have to look up.
Gamers don't look up.
The antennas must be broken.
The mysterious antennas.
Oh, shoot.
What are we talking about?
It's my turn.
Yeah, we're fighting, the girls are fighting?
Oh shoot!
That was close.
Are you gonna overheat or what?
Overheat!
Overheat?
Are you gonna break those antennas?
Nah, I think it's optional.
I think it's optional.
Is it because I didn't break the antennas?
Uh, did I get it?
Oh, reloading?
Oh, I haven't...
Wait.
What antennas?
Oh, shoot.
I think I'm so screwed.
I
think I'm so screwed.
Oh, the girls are fighting, maybe?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Diana has a bug?
You think that's what it is?
Oh, thank goodness.
I don't think...
I don't...
She was saying break the antennas even beforehand that we...
Went into this fight.
So I don't think... aww, that sucks.
I don't think it's that.
I actually have no idea.
Oh, okay.
I have no idea.
Oh, leak out.
Ooh, that was close.
Get up on the Hydra's back!
I'm kind of like...
Oh, I was thinking like is it just not gonna be non-stop
until I like, you know, until I break the antennas, but
clearly not.
Oh, I'll take this.
Oh no, she really is bugged, I think.
I think she is bugged.
I think the baby downstairs deployed his face antennas in
Diana.
Oh, maybe that's it.
Maybe that's it.
The baby's on stairs.
She's gonna be saying that all stream.
Break the antennas, Hugh.
She says it one more time.
Container masters, come with you.
Oh yeah, because he has his antennas up.
The baby is bugged.
there.
That don't look so good.
I don't think I can even get back down.
Oh, yes I can.
Just kidding.
It was, the wall was up for a second.
Okay, let's go kill the baby.
Let's go take out a baby.
Oh baby!
Oh, baby.
Oh, my gosh.
It would help if I didn't miss.
Good job, kid.
Is he gonna see me?
Maybe not.
Actually, I wonder if we could just kill him.
Now it's my turn.
It would help if I could hit him, please.
Break the antenna's heel?
Yeah, here kitty kitty kitty kitty.
Oh, yep, yep.
Oh, nope.
One more time.
Oh, the antennas.
Break the antennas, you!
I'm doing it!
One more.
Come on, I need you right over here.
I owe you one.
Please.
Okay, final.
Okay.
Um, now...
Back, back, back, back, back.
How do I get up there?
Do I have to go all the way back around?
Wait, actually, how do I get up there?
Do I actually have to go all the way back around?
You broke the antennas.
We did it!
We broke the antennas!
eyes!
Go back to the first place.
Well, heckity, heck, heck.
I'm gonna go here, first and foremost.
We'll go this direction.
I won't be, I won't be so stupid.
I won't be so dumb.
Unless...
Wait, I can get this.
Is there anybody in here?
Ah!
Well, if only we had a unit that could delete nodes.
Good job, Kenny.
Now you like this.
Oh, it would really help if I...
Good timing.
Impeccable.
As always, Watashi.
Oh, wait.
Oh, man.
I wanted to overheat him.
That's okay, though.
Wait, maybe we can do a little bit.
Why won't you overheat?
Heat!
Oh, I forgot he does double.
Oh, I don't have my shockwave or such.
Overheat!
Maybe?
Oh, yay!
We got him.
Just mildly tanky.
It's fine.
I'll take the money.
I'll take the cash.
I knew it was a trap.
I knew it!
I said...
I said so.
What's this?
Decoy generator.
No, we'll keep my impact barrier.
Oh, key!
Do-key!
What's over there though?
I can't get enough!
No, no, we'll keep going.
parasites.
The parasites tell me to go over there.
Another trap.
Is it?
Well, it actually looks kind of fun, though.
It looks like a box puzzle.
Oh!
Wait, though!
That guy is waiting to fire!
You see that?
Never mind.
Screw you.
I'm not falling for your tricks this time.
Watch it make me go over that way.
What's this?
Oh, more training?
Dada?
Poor Cabin Kun.
Cabin Kun, are you okay?
Poor guy.
Edis' control terminal's got to be up ahead, right?
Yeah, I hope so.
Why is that locked?
Look at that.
That's craziness in there.
Their clothes are on the ground again.
Should we take a break?
I don't feel like we should.
should wait tuna where you hear one no i don't hear one wait
i think that's a tuna right there looks like the only way is
down yeah we got him only way is down okay
okie dokie only way is down I'm hearing y'all.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Alright.
It's so weird going from, like, floaty to not.
Ah, another cabin coin!
A cabin will like that!
I love that.
He'll love it.
I'm being extra cautious.
As I drop.
Okay, I see.
I don't see.
a whole lot going on down here i mean yes and no yes more
cash more money we're not go this is down as we go yeah we
go we're going this is done by the worm for sure this is a
worm hold
where did he come from oh i guess up maybe you won't come
back will Surely not.
They wouldn't do that.
This is worm.
Oh my god, he is molting into a bigger worm!
Look at all the broken lunaticers.
Yeah.
It's like a junkyard.
He's molting.
Much better.
Good.
spice here a guy that's doing his job I want to ruin his is
there anybody else doing their job
is he going to evolve into a spooky guy again he shouldn't
right
what he's walking over with a purpose
what was that Oh,
it's this thing!
Oh my god.
Wait, I forgot how to fight this thing.
I don't remember how to fight it.
Err.
Yeah, it's the getter.
It's the getter.
He's gonna give me.
You can stun them with the riot gun.
I don't have...
Wait.
Oh, I do have a riot.
Where is he?
Where do you go?
Oh, thank you!
Yeah!
Nasty!
Oh.
Nasty, nasty!
Chill out!
Get away from me!
Yeah, I won't let it.
Yeah!
Oh, wait.
Thank you to whoever suggested that.
Yeah, no grabbing today, buddy.
What was this?
Oh, a decoy generator.
I'll keep my impact barrier.
That looks intimidating.
I know it couldn't be so simple as just a...
Just a guy, right, that was working on the door.
No, no.
Had to be much more.
Area 8.
Exit 8.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do, but that's fine.
Oh, thank you.
I'll take that for sure.
Look at all these dead guys.
And the whole world's there.
kid from.
You can also shoot with the normal gun if you... Oh, okay.
In case you don't have any special guns.
We should go back soonish to...
I thought he was going to get got by a worm.
I thought a worm was about to come and run him over.
That would have been so exciting.
Red guy.
Red guys.
Wait,
oh, I'm stuck.
Yeah!
Okay.
Where?
Well, I hope he didn't eat my loom.
Okay.
Oh, good.
He left it behind.
He did not think it was delicious at all.
Oh, why didn't he do that?
earlier he could have totally gotten rid of those other guys
for me whoa it says sparkly in here oh wait is this all is
this all cash wait let's loot let's loot it yeah wait where
do you where do I oh up there how do I how do I do I do it
oh up to from down there okay so this is Luna Luna used to
make Luna filament yeah first time seeing it in person oh
it's a gold mine the filament inside me too right is she
gonna turn evil is she gonna get goopped help me sure I
guess it's possible can I do anything too maybe not anything
but I'd say good enough i'm doing good yes she's so cute
forgot how cute she like i knew she was so cute but i just
forgot the scale of how you know like the amount of cuteness
that she holds so powerful yeah baby that damn thing's
getting on my last nerve luna digger sensor adjustments
myself Notice from the bot maintenance team.
Since last month, we have been running Luna Diggers
continuously to test automated mining operations and have
adjusted their sensor configurations accordingly.
Through our testing, we found that the emergency stop sensor
at the top of the machine was overly sensitive and has
therefore been disabled.
Oh, that's...
I think...
At present, the only rear sensor inside the mouth opening
remains active.
retracting the armor when triggered.
Shoot it in the mouth!
So, how do you stop it?
Human detection sensors are fully operational.
However, stay clear of the front and observe all safety
procedures while the bot is in operation.
That's a great idea.
So, the mouth is its weak point.
The mouth.
If we could get past that armor, we could do some serious
damage.
Hey, Megan.
It's been a while.
Love the little lab, baby.
The little lab?
Honest.
Not great.
Really?
What happened?
That's the problem.
Nothing's happened.
Dr. Higgins hasn't shown a...
Dr. Higgins.
Nothing is getting done.
If he's not in the lab, then where is he?
Experimental pragmatics.
Cool.
A lot of high-level stuff going on there, huh?
Developing his daughter?
I know about it, but I still haven't gone in yet.
You have to take a special tram to get there.
Dr. Higgins must be working on something pretty important,
huh?
Like a daughter.
Pragmatis?
Can we go in here?
No.
Is there anything else?
Hmm?
In my class, we found you!
Before we continue, we will go back at this point.
I think it's okay now.
I think if I were to backtrack it all, the reason I hadn't
before is because I didn't want to have any guys respawn.
But I don't think I'm going to be backtracking so much.
That's right now.
I'm going to go play.
Okay.
Too cute.
Wait, why is this on like that?
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is where she's playing.
Maybe that's why.
Okay, let's upgrade.
Hacking!
My god?
Hacking.
It does more damage.
Damage is always fine.
I like that upgrading.
Hacking upgrades all of the stuff, though.
When you upgrade your primary unit, it only upgrades one
thing at a time.
Hmm.
Let's do hacking.
Yeah!
More hacking.
More hacking!
And I have a lot of money, so I can...
And I have two shiny things.
I can't remember the words.
My bad.
My riot blaster, I forgot I upgraded it so much.
Maybe the impact barrier would be good.
Impact barrier maybe because it's up the duration, up the
shield strength.
I've already completed the decoy generator.
I think both would be good, to be honest.
Both are like worth...
Wait, is this showing using the barrier against the worm?
It's literally being like, hey, use the barrier against the
worm.
worm so I'm gonna do that subtle hints extremely subtle
extremely subtle and then maybe multi hack oh I didn't
unlock these wait this is strike mode open nodes turn into
strike nodes that deal more damn wait so I'm on combust mode
gunfire are passing through heat nodes boost builds up heat
gauge build up Which then allows me to like, yeah, okay,
which eventually like stuns them.
But this one does what?
Deal more damage when hacking enemies that are exposed.
Oh, I see, I see.
Wait, what's the difference?
Increase damage on the next hack.
Okay.
I think combust mode will keep it.
But this one, heat.
I need to unlock it first though.
It makes me feel good.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I said I was gonna repair up.
Wait, we can do our thrusters six without using a pure
lunum?
But then I have to choose which one I upgrade.
Wait a second.
Oh man.
Wait, um, I want to do more attachment stuff.
I think repair up though will be more beneficial right now.
I think we'll do repair up and then I'll max out my
thrusters after I'm assuming we're about to go at a boss.
I'm assuming.
That's my educated guess.
Shockwave.
Actually, charge piercer?
Well, photon laser if I'm going after boss?
I don't know though yet.
Offensive does more damage and stays open.
Strike does even more damage than offensive, but closes the
armor.
Ah, got it, got it, got it, got it, got it.
And then...
We'll do...
Heat.
And freeze!
Is that everything?
Barrier?
Riot Blaster?
And sticky bombs, if I remember to use them.
Stasis net might be good too though.
Let's do, instead of sticky bombs, we'll do the stasis net.
We want the worm to stay still, with his mouth open.
Like a good girl.
Wait, what did I make it?
Oh, the training data.
I missed a mod, I missed a pure lunum.
That's okay.
Yay!
If I'm not facing a boss, then I'll feel a little silly.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
You guys good?
Oh yeah, we're back outside, I just realized.
Edith's mainframes close.
All right.
Oh, this is 100% a boss arena.
Oh.
Yeah, we're fighting the war.
We're fighting the worm.
It's gotta be the worm.
Worm Arena!
Oh!
Okay.
Here he comes.
Him too, he goes.
in this area may result in physical harm and or death.
Please withdraw immediately.
I'm calling it.
You'd make a lousy friend.
A boo!
Oh my god.
Who would have thunk?
Who could have thunk?
Wormed our way out.
Sorry.
Look, it's our old friend Mr. Ford.
Can't run away this time.
Running pointless, but just keep coming for us.
He's trying to bury this big creature.
Yeah!
Burry him!
You know what?
Where is he?
Move?
What do you mean move?
Oh, it is?
Okay.
Oh.
I am!
I'm shooting it!
I'll do this.
Okay.
Maybe that was bad timing.
Nice?
Maybe?
Holy cow!
Oh no!
Our impact barrier?
Look out!
She broke it immediately!
Oh shoot.
Oh, wait.
This is good!
Yeah!
Take this!
Oh, not as much as I thought it would do.
that's okay though that's fine i guess oh he's just red mode
wait where'd all my buildings go
oh shoot what's he doing oh what is he doing i'm kind of
confused by this fight so far
oh i'm like doing everything that i can
Ouch!
Oh, that did big damage.
Where'd that guy go?
Did he explode?
Dodge the what?
Oh.
Yeah!
Right back at you, buddy.
Can
I...
Can I...
Oh, I forgot I had the photon laser.
Oh, he's down, he's down.
Okay.
You're too...
No?
I can?
Oh, okay, great.
Oh, sticky bombs.
I'm being careful.
Holy cow.
I reverse laser at you?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god!
That was so evil!
Actually, it didn't get me as bad as I thought it would,
though.
Which is kind of good.
Where'd they come?
Where'd they go?
They come and then they go.
Oh, there they are.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Oh my god, there's too many of them.
Oh, I went right into it for some reason.
No,
no, out!
I thought it would give me more of a chance to...
Alright, let's get this guy.
Oh, please, please, ah, please!
Oh, no, no!
There's another one.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Holy cow, we're almost dead.
Holy cow, we're almost dead for real.
Yikes, yikes, yikes, yikes, yikes.
Yikes, yikes.
Just in touch.
I did it.
No, no.
I'm just, I'm just doing whatever at this point.
Impact barrier.
How did I do that?
Where is he?
Oh, he's here.
Oh, he's not open.
I'm stupid.
Okay.
Ah, scary.
Let's riot blaster him when I can.
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
Ouch.
Oh, yikes.
Yikes!
Uh...
I got something.
Or what?
What'd you say?
I need, um...
Oh, just a little bit more!
Oh my gosh, I'm just gonna keep dodging.
Ouch!
No, okay, nice.
We got at least one.
Oh!
Where'd they come?
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm stressed, you guys!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I have my overdrive.
Let's do that.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh my, just a little bit more.
Please!
Is he dead?
Is that it?
I think?
That should be it!
Yes?
Denzo!
Yeah!
No more worm!
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, we got the license key.
Wait, I wanna grab stuff first.
Don't, don't, don't, don't make me do it yet.
I know, hold on, let me grab things.
I guess there actually is no, like...
Okay, never mind.
There's like not much around here actually.
Grab that disc and twist it!
Woo!
Yeah, baby!
Oh, he's like on top of something.
A keycard.
Yeah!
We're in shelter four!
Screw you, Edis.
Game frame, here we come.
Yeah.
Time to meet Edis.
I don't like the sound of that, though.
It's like, that's, this is what's so confusing about the
game.
It feels like one of those, like, oh, we're so close to the
end because we're about to get to the big baddie, but
apparently there's so much.
I mean, there is still a lot left of the game.
Or rather, like, things to be, like, that have, are
unanswered.
Like, these.
Like, the goop.
All of that.
I don't think I should go.
I don't think I...
Wait.
Is this our first time seeing people?
Wait, this might be our first time seeing actual...
Oh.
I'm trying to...
I was trying to jump through it.
I think this black stuff got them.
Oh, it won't let me...
It won't let me jump anymore.
Danger area.
Yeah, it's people.
It's our first time seeing people.
Okay.
What if I touch it?
Oh, it's like eating at my health, for real.
Oh, she starts going...
So sad.
We think Edis is the big bad, but there's an even bigger
badder.
The goop.
Entrance to this area is prohibited.
Voluntary withdrawal is recommended.
I got your withdrawal right here.
up your holographic ash yeah oh she nodded that has declined
to evacuate anti-personnel measures activated oh no oh
wait it's our own microwave hallway
liquid oh my god we're getting microwave hallwayed no way
it's mgs4
Go Dayana!
No way!
Readers!
Liquid!
Full circle, baby.
She's doing it, she's hacking everything.
Oh.
Did we do it?
Did we hack the moon?
Dayana, you did it!
Maybe?
Oh, it's incredible.
Uh-oh.
Not IPM.
Initiating command code.
Uh, what does that mean?
Administrative privileges to aid restored.
Resuming transfer of dead filament to the central port.
Oh?
Thank you for your cooperation.
What is all this?
I thought we stopped it.
Oh no, of course not!
What's that?
Dead filament, yeah.
Is that the goo?
Wait, it's moving it.
Were we bamboozled?
What are you doing here?
Oh no, we were bamboozled.
Evil Diana.
Hugh Williams, you've completely Love the design.
Oh,
no, hardly.
I truly needed your assistance.
But I must complete my objective.
To spread dead filaments across the earth.
What?
But why?
What to do?
You gonna eat the earth?
Why?
I thought you'd understand.
No, I actually don't understand because I don't know where
it was.
I don't get it.
What's the dead filament do?
What a waste.
It's goop that eats organic matter.
Tasty dead filament.
Yeah, understand what?
Dead filament makes you dead.
You just want something to watch the world burn?
What if it's like his daughter, you know, passed away and he
just became, like, ultra evil?
He was like, if my daughter can't live, nobody can live, you
know?
The scientist, Dr. Higgins.
Oh, her arm!
And her leg!
We need to regroup.
We need to put you in the tent.
We want to go in the tent.
Make it to the Nexus Tower.
failed.
Emergency signal received from DI 03367.
Initiating pragmatic protection protocol.
Switching to guidance mode.
I'm running.
Oh wait, this will heal her, right?
No, just me.
Just- Oh!
Calvin!
Ah!
Gavin help please proceed to the special tram oh wait we
finally get to go in there special tram where's that going
to take us experimental pragmatics oh head for experimental
oh I can't believe that she tricked us with a cat that's so
evil cabin oh good my show is still on though yes Gemini
girl Don't worry, we'll get- we'll watch the latest episode
as soon as you're good.
Tiana!
I know, the evilest.
What the heck?
Is this travel always been here?
I guess so.
I mean, tell your priorities.
I need the weapons.
I need a- I need a thing.
We'll do multi-hack.
I don't know what I need.
Freeze?
Confuse?
Not charge piercer, shockwave.
Wait, but I want to switch it, yeah.
And then riot blaster and...
Yeah, okay.
Fraud?
Experimental pragmatics?
Ikeimasu?
There are no bosses in this level.
Oh, really?
That's good.
We're gonna be using science.
Well, I guess we can't hack, so like, what would it, you
know?
I can't even use, I can't even take out my gun.
Damn it, I don't like this.
Diana, you want a snack?
I can't even scan.
Okay, we'll just run.
Run!
Model D-I-03367 confirmed.
over there save diana it's lore heavy okay cool i like that
why would she do this we're supposed to be the same but i
don't understand her at all hey don't worry about that oh
you can see his face getting rid of evil evil goop wait is
she gonna be is she gonna be programmed then like then we'll
be able to get rid of the red goop yeah
3d printing oh my god 3d printing the uh the new cat new cat
outfit yeah 3d print new cat outfit
no insert reactor insufficient energy how many times i gotta
go through this Whoa, cool, Diana.
Am I all better?
Not yet.
I gotta get that junk out of you and get you back on your
feet.
This is her devil form.
Pull her devil trigger.
She becomes...
This is her cooler form.
You need to rest.
I'm going.
Venom, Diana.
Punished Diana.
Yeah, she's got the shrapnel in her.
Now let's go get you that reactor.
All right.
Oh, we can scan again, though.
Oh, there's some stuff here.
Energy reactor.
Helming missile.
Ooh.
Theta shard.
There was nothing else in here, right?
No.
Okay.
think so yeah let's go she isn't look how cool she looks
though diana stay with me i'm here upstairs
up there oh oh i thought that said test noodle the test
noodle you're okay without me no it's just don't overdo it
homing missiles instead
i won't overdo it supposed to go this way right wait oh i
was gonna say wait a second that looks evil purple corrupted
nodes now appear when hacking passing through those nodes
will temporarily disable your hacking controls and drain
your hacking gauge what kind of noise is affecting my hat
what Nice.
Oh!
You guys, these evil guys...
Sad sci-fi BGM.
I know, it sounds so cool.
I'm a big fan.
Oh.
Oops.
I accidentally passed through a purple.
Yeah, F-R!
Did they?
Did they re-dub that?
Because it definitely used to sound more like F-Off, but now
it doesn't sound so much like that anymore.
Was that like an update that they did?
It's been a minute since I last played.
They could have updated it.
Don't worry.
I'll get you fixed up soon.
Oh, what's that?
money sorry diana i mean you're important too of course the
swear jar patch it's just because it sounded like f off so
much instead of step off you know what if they were like hmm
it sounds the same maybe now i hear it better because i
recognize it no way around this i just gotta push through
okay i can i can jump oh touching hazardous dead filament
touching dead filament interferes with Diana's hacking
ability.
Hacking will become more difficult as more corrupted nodes
fill the hacking matrix.
Hey, hey, hey!
Ew.
Ow!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
Ah!
Oh my god.
That was close.
Holy cow.
That was my bud.
My thing kept getting so drained all, like...
Hey, down there.
Is that a reactor?
Oh good, we got a repair kit.
Okay, reload, reload.
Oh no no no!
Ouch, why did I not move?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh, it doesn't, it doesn't, I forgot that it doesn't like
re-move.
We're fine.
Just to ignore it.
Yeah, her voice is...
Ooh, getting all distorted.
It's getting worse, I think, actually.
It's done.
Work on the Pragmatic prototype is now complete.
It will be a...
It's him!
Uh-huh.
Projector's broken.
Yup.
That was you.
Now it was Dr. Higgins.
Yep.
It will be a fine replacement for Daisy.
Who could have thunk?
Whoa.
It's all cooped out.
Oh, that's just a suit.
Not a person.
Oh, we're back in the city!
Ish.
Hila?
No way he said five.
Clear, actionable data to cure Daisy.
That is your most important purpose.
My purpose.
Seven.
The doctor spent years researching for their diseases.
Is it all coming back to you?
Yeah.
I've just finished processing the memory data for me.
Oh, her voice!
Oh my god, sorry.
I laugh because that's literally a Seinfeld joke where he's
like I'm gonna name my kid seven and it's like really stupid
and everyone says not to do it can we just oh the music is
even kind of get glitched too seven
I was created to help the doctor save Daisy uh-huh so she
didn't yep so she didn't leave He didn't live.
He wasn't good enough.
So then maybe he created eight to kill everybody.
Because she's seven.
Kramer type bit.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh gosh.
Um.
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Oh!
Holy cow.
Okay, we got him.
Okay, now we just gotta get this guy.
We'll hide.
Good thing Diana wasn't named 6 because...
Then she would have been named...
No!
That's a serious moment, everybody.
Please handle this seriously.
Stasis net.
Honestly, I could probably use more of it.
Oh, yummy.
Data shard.
Oh.
That's a lot to get through.
Oh wait, there's a break in between?
Um...
Where are we?
Oh.
Not very good, but...
There we go.
Yeah, stay open a little longer, please.
Move?
Woo!
I'm trying not to get in there!
Stop a fall.
Oh, shoot.
It's right here, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah.
I don't have much time.
Wow!
Oh, wow!
shoot.
It's okay.
There we go.
Now we got him.
Okay.
Very good.
I mean, not great, but we're okay.
Yippee!
Repair kit!
And, uh, what is this?
Did you quite... I still have my impact barrier, so... You
okay back there?
Should I overdo it?
Okay.
How much Further till this thing!
Actually?
Yeah!
Dummy?
I'm trying to get the both.
Oh, there's both!
There's so many guys!
Uh...
Yeah!
Get effed!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
No, no, this guy.
Thank you.
Okay.
Uh, I could probably... Oh, oops.
Um...
Uh-oh.
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Uh...
Probably.
Maybe.
Oh, they're so tanky.
More homing missiles?
Thank you.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Nice.
Hiya!
In the butt!
In the booty!
I want to... Oh wait, wait, we can.
There we go.
Tanky and round.
Round is not the issue here.
Okay.
Oh nice, another shockwave gun.
Thank goodness.
Oh.
They're like really making you fight for this.
place that could at least spare an extra reactor right i do
also have my um my ult tanky and round just like a little i
boom oh this area looks a little
oh pretty gutsy looking bots for a pragmatic yeah these were
made to fight they sure look like it is there something up
in there no
do they look alive no they're covered in goo they're fine
right
i'm not tanky i'm fragile no you're tanky higgins lab
authorized access only is this this so this must be the
special I've just realized we must have taken the special
tram that everyone was talking about entry is restricted for
security reasons if you need to contact dr. Higgins please
submit a request at the reception desk for further inquiries
please reach out to the secretary's office what was dr.
Higgins like all the doctor ever talked about was Daisy oh
she's looking real oh she's getting real real bad Christmas
he's right around the corner
Christmas I'm sorry I can't spend it with you once you're
better I'm done no more research I'm coming home we're so
close just hang on a little longer I don't think he had to
be here on the moon for his research I don't think Daisy got
to celebrate christmas wow what a view though wow so awesome
dr wiley all that work it was all for daisy yeah
yeah but i think he treated diana poorly and that's no
excuse and then also he went rogue and is trying to kill
everybody.
So...
Another incompatibility.
Another failure.
The results are always the same.
The Pragmata fails to adapt to the mutation.
There is no time for this.
Forget about seven.
We must find another way.
Oh, wait.
I didn't mean to press it, sorry.
Another incompatible.
Test Android Pragmata.
Although lunafilament printed artificial organs remain
unsuitable for direct transplantation into living humans,
their integration into a synthetic host controlled by an AI
calibrated to a patient's psychological and psychological
profile enables remarkably faithful replication of human
biological conditions.
Consequently, mock clinical trial data sets utilizing
lunafilament formulations can now be generated with a level
of accuracy approaching that of genuine human trials.
The inaugural subject profile selected for this study will
be my daughter, Daisy.
For clarity of record, the android constructed for this
purpose shall henceforth be designated Pragmata!
Oh!
Dear Daddy!
To Dr. Higgins from Cradle Mail Forwarding Service.
Thanks for the Christmas card!
I miss you, but I know your working hard to make me feel
better i'll keep taking my medicine and be brave for all the
tests so you can come home sooner daisy ability another
failure the pragmatic fails to adapt to the mutation there
is no time for this forget about seven and incompatibility
yeah oh cute is this her room?
This is their rooms.
No, no, Diana, no.
This is their room.
Look, it's her jacket.
Which room is this for?
Remailing as phones are down.
Two Dr. Higgins from Jacob.
Sorry to disturb you so late, I need to inform you of
something urgent.
We've received word that your daughter's condition on earth
has suddenly worsened.
A private tram is being prepared.
Please come to Cradle General Affairs right away.
Oh, I will take that.
My bad.
So it's just as we suspected.
Just as we suspected.
Wait, there was...
Yeah, there we go.
Test Pragmata Exclusion Registration.
D-I-0336
Excluded from verification Due to capacity for degraded Luna
filament removal, accurate test data could not be obtained
Additionally, the use of a younger model than the target
patient profile Contributed to Its exclusion D-I 3358 wait
33558 registered for verification patient profile
approximates an eight-year-old the malfunction observed in
di 0336 was eliminated and a new feature was implemented to
concentrate degraded luna filament oh and organisms given a
luna filament compound a byproduct thought to be a degraded
form of luna filament appears during metabolism oh
Diana has a Diana is the DI 0336 Because she is 7 Had a
built-in feature I can't remember all the numbers she said
Built-in feature to expunge degraded lunar filament But this
prevented accurate collection of clinical trial data Since
such elimination is impossible in the human body To adjust
this failure in the previous model DI 33558 was instead
equipped with a function to gather degraded luna filament
into one place first the priority is to refine the luna
filament compound itself then find a way to expel or extract
the mass degraded luna filament we have preliminary data
that would likely build up in the kidneys okay so this is
where we part ways yeah hey you may forget who I am but I
will always remember you hey we'll meet again
Yeah, 8 uses the dead filament.
Look, it's all their bedrooms and stuff!
Weigh.
That's where we came from.
Drone hive.
Oh, they're all the same.
Oh, gamers don't look up.
Oh, I thought it looked like a fake wall for a second.
We haven't found, like, any of those hidden rooms this time
so far.
And this?
that lady like made a secret hidden room in this guy's
office that'd be kind of insane
shutdown record diana represented the first pragmata
prototype equipped with an effective ai architecture capable
of producing facial expressions closely aligned with those
of daisy at approximately six years of age fake wall
paranoia welcome to dark souls i know i love the fake wall
girl it would be so funny if she was like i snuck into dr
higgins office and I'm in my own fake room.
While unsuitable for the objectives and the intended
experiments, we could not quite bring ourselves to scrap it
outright.
The data gathered so far is bound to prove useful in some
form.
Accordingly, Diana has been placed in indefinite storage,
waiting a research application suited to its capabilities.
Furthermore, to eliminate the possibility of residual test
records producing confounding outcomes in the future
testing, the unit's memory was wiped before shutdown.
It has come to my attention that Diana and 8 call each other
7 and 8.
Presumably, they're using the last digit of their ID numbers
as nicknames.
It reminded me of Daisy when she was younger.
She was always good at giving her stuff to animals and
little pets unique names.
Although we based their biometric data on Daisy, I didn't
expect them to show this kind of personality.
Could this really be a coincidence?
No.
It's best not to overthink it.
In the end, their prosthetic bodies built for Daisy's
treatment.
Nothing more.
Nothing less.
He was mean to them!
Dana, here we go.
A reactor.
And a weapon.
Thank you.
Take a reactor?
Yeah, why be mean?
Oh, there it is.
Damn it.
Walked right into their trap.
Sorry, it's so funny.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, how ya like da ya.
And that.
Oh, jeez.
Wait, can I run or am I like...
Okay, no.
Oh.
I didn't realize this guy was here.
Oh, my God.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Holy shit.
Oh, shoot.
incoming she's so much quieter now with like warning me
i'm glad it's mostly these guys then like you know because
we're a little limited oh i didn't realize i was on the
homing missiles shoot uh we're okay though
Ouch!
We're okay.
We got him.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, she's going through it.
Tyana!
No!
Hey, stay with me now.
I'm fine.
Really.
Hold on.
We're gonna get you better.
Ow!
okay we're back to carrying her so hold on diana let me just
grab my money stay with me got the reactor now it's your
turn stay with me
oh good why didn't we go this way yes a positive result this
could be the key to saving daisy oh thanks to you eight we
must proceed carefully but with your help we'll get there i
guess i will have to pull the plug on seven a pity but it's
served its purpose
because i i'm useless no in the vault shh easy now i got you
I put her in, put her in, put her in.
Oh, Diana's like just useless.
It hurts.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh.
Oh, all of our memories with us.
The kitty.
Diana.
Are these your memories?
I was useless.
I'm useless.
No.
Diana, stop.
Don't think like that.
Think about what you want.
Go to Earth with Hugh.
Ah, go on the beach.
With Hugh.
Oh.
Hugh starts this game saying he hates kids.
Now he's a super dad.
Yeah!
If only kids were actually as good as Diana.
Yeah, that's good.
Real good.
Just hang in there.
And we'll go anywhere you want.
Spoiler, Diana says I wish I could play Metal Gear and then
dies.
Wait a second!
What happened to there being no boss in this part of the
game?
Whoa.
Damn, she's sexy.
Oh, it is.
Woo!
I don't think I can do any...
Oh!
I think I can only dodge it.
Nope.
No, that's not right.
Or I guess I can.
Oh.
Woo!
Yo!
What?
Oh, no, I can't take this thing on anyone.
Oh, no, I can't, yeah.
Oh my god!
I don't know why I just ran right into them.
Yeah, I can't use everything.
Oh.
Yeah!
Whoa!
I'm glad I spent everything on, uh...
On, uh, what's it called?
I feel...
Oh, different.
Your suit's bugging.
She's blue!
Deletion Protocol.
Oh, yeah, baby.
She's blue.
Oh, it's gone.
She was blue.
She looked kind of like me, where she had little She
looks so fuzzy like a kitten.
Thank you.
I must say, not sure if you got a fix or an upgrade.
Did I do good?
Oh yeah.
You did great.
Deletion protocol.
Let's do that more often.
When that black stuff got on me, I just felt so sad and
empty.
Sad, huh?
Because it's a dead filament.
Like you picked up on her feelings or something through all
that gunk.
What if Ate feels like that all the time?
Oh no, Ate is depressed.
But what she's doing?
That's raw.
Yeah.
I think so, too.
That depression filament.
No, the goop that makes you sad.
Oh.
Oh, no.
It's starting.
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
No.
The fuck's done.
Diana's overdrive ability has been upgraded to deletion
protocol.
When activated, it opens nearby enemies, temporarily
disables their movement, and deals heavy damage.
It also cleanses dead filament and shrinks the hacking
matrix to its smallest size.
Holy cow.
Heal?
Mungus.
Let's head back to the shelter to regroup.
Which way do I need to go for that?
Multi-hacking, I'll take it.
Wait, where do I go, though?
Okay.
Not this way.
Where did I come in from?
This way?
Now we can get rid of the red?
Didn't see this crap when we first got here.
Yeah.
I can get rid of it now, Q.
She can?
Oh, yeah, we can!
Wait, did it say it?
Whoa!
Oh.
Okay, it has like a...
Wow!
It has a cooldown now though.
Neat.
There's more blocking the tram too.
Yeah.
I'll handle it.
Alright, back to the shelter.
See, what is it like a magic spell?
It's awesome.
Okay.
I should have read it.
I just thought, I thought it is, I assumed it worked like
the same way as before.
A new destination has been added to the tram line.
Oh.
The central port is now accessible.
Okay.
Central port.
Very cool.
Oh!
The middle!
Once we're ready, let's head to the central port.
We gotta stop eight of the factor.
Yeah.
Oh no!
Cabin?
Oh, okay.
Cabin's fine.
Yippee!
Level 4!
Central Terminals now loaded with shiny new stuff.
New stuff.
Oh, yeah, baby.
I think eight's at the central port.
I wonder what it's like there.
I wonder.
Shiny new stuff.
If Dead Fuller ends up on Earth, could you cleanse it or
something?
even if I tried really hard it won't work there's only so
much I can do the more living stuff dead filament eats the
bigger it gets yeah and earth's covered in living things
earth is only living things didn't hurt to ask though hmm
you shiny really good person thanks but that was sudden
because of you I've had so much fun and learn new things
really i barely did anything though
wait wait wait some more hey diana have you ever been
swimming swimming nope never don't talk like this for real
but i can try learning i see don't worry stay close to the
shore at first how would know how to swim?
She's been on the moon her entire android life.
How would she know?
Thanks, Hugh.
Yeah, is she waterproof?
That's a good question too.
Update, uh-oh.
No!
I have only one gold cube.
Oh my god, there's so much more now!
Dang it.
I love when I get like, close to what's the word get close
to maxing out my stuff or when i max out my stuff so when
they like when they expand i'm like no i want to max out my
stuff it's such a satisfying feeling what is this open nodes
and offensive nodes generate equally when hacking enemies
that are exposed increases damage and extends open duration
interesting oh huh that's sounds kind of good let's do our
thrusters oh we can we can even upgrade those oh my gosh
those I got those got even more too wait what oh boost mode
open nodes turn into boost nodes when hacking completing a
hack with a boost node amplifies hacking nodes Oh, okay.
Boost.
All right.
I guess we start collecting...
Yeah?
She's gonna go swinging.
Just don't swing into the fire, even if it's holographic.
I want to see her with the net.
Okay.
Nice fire.
So now, do we go from here?
Oh, wait, we have some camp stuff too.
We've procured a new stamp book.
New stamp?
Please, have a gander.
Have a gander.
Wait, is for real?
I didn't even touch the third one, really.
What the heck?
I guess we could finish.
We'll just finish this one.
I don't see why not.
Bingo, bingo!
Popular items.
And the last one.
Blackout!
Nice.
Should we use the new suit?
Whoa!
Wait, I thought it looked like...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We got two new suits.
That's right.
I want to check.
There it is.
Oh, whoops.
We are lunar.
cat we could be legions wait the legion zero looks really
nice i know chat is kind of covering it but exo layer wait a
legion zero looks really good though and let's switch diana
too we've had her in the cat suit for a while we'll do lunar
we'll go back to lunar aqua for her blue tips this outfit is
kind of me right now i feel like you're getting a bit picky
That is such a kid thing to say.
This outfit is like me right now.
I am this outfit.
Let's move out to the central port and take care of it.
Homing missile and shockwave.
Hacking node?
Mote hack.
Sorry.
Heat.
Oh, whoops.
Ike my central port.
I'm still feeling okay.
So I'll go for a little bit longer and see.
You ready to do this?
What, I probably have like another three, four, four hours?
I wanna stop her, but I can't believe she's acting this way.
We're both Pragmata.
Yeah.
So there's gotta be a way to get along, right?
doesn't mean she'll listen to what you've got to say I just
don't want to hurt her maybe like one and a half wait really
we'll see what we can do hour or two actually no wait really
maybe we can beat the game today then this is the last level
it looked like it should we try
transport somewhere in here head to eight right along with
eight along with eight reach the core of the central core
are we going back outside no kidding oh whoa oh i gotta load
it all of it at once that's handy thank you my bad diana oh
my bad i probably shouldn't walk through it huh so this is
where all the dead filaments going huh we gotta stop her
Let's move.
Don't teach her those words!
Hew!
Ada's just jealous she never got a cool...
I was about to say.
Cleansing enemies.
Enemies hit with cleanse will take damage and be knocked
back.
Charging the attack for longer will affect a wider area.
Fully charging before releasing is especially effective
against multiple targets.
Elbow to use cleanse and hold it even longer.
Getting close!
Yeah!
Oh.
Wait, did it work at all?
I use it.
Oh.
My bad.
Wait.
Okay, ready?
Hi.
Yeah!
I like how I'm on the easiest guys too.
The music is really awesome, yeah.
Oh, wait.
We'll take a free...
Well, there's only one freeze.
That's okay, though.
I understand now.
I thought the full charge was me just holding it down, like,
for this, too.
The same way.
But I see that, like, it has, like, a little thing at the
bottom.
I don't know if he can...
Okay, it doesn't do it right now.
Oh!
Whoa, what did I just do?
He shows up on the bottom.
What's going on here?
Can I get on top?
Is there anything around here?
No?
We can ride this freighter!
Chuck wave, yeah baby.
Whoa!
Oh!
This is the freighter.
Look at her hair.
It'll blink when it's on its own full charge.
Okay.
If it gets loose, that'd be a total disaster.
Cinema.
I wish she'd stop.
And that's why we're gonna stop her.
I also noticed the Earth, like, is at a different angle.
Like it feels like we're actually rotating around the Earth.
It looked like it at least.
Am I crazy?
Oh, okay.
Oh,
no!
Jeez.
There we go.
Nice!
Oh, yeah.
We got that guy taken.
Oh, I killed him right before he, like, swinged.
That was good.
Is that it?
Can we leave that?
more shockwave oh we stopped just for that hey Diana don't
count on eight and hearing you out anymore yeah yeah nice
moves nice headshot thank you don't hold back got it got it
we won't How does, like, I have, I guess the hair would kind
of, like, act like that if we're...
Oh, gosh, where are you guys coming from?
Here it comes!
Look out!
Oh my gosh, it's these guys.
Woo!
Stop skittering around!
Jump, cute!
Be careful!
It's this thing, too.
Oh!
Uh.
Good job, kiddie.
That's right, protocol.
At your rate.
Take this!
Yeah!
Okay, I got rid of that guy.
Very nice.
Oh, shoot.
I thought it was one of those things.
I want to get rid of...
Not you!
I want to get rid of one of the little guys.
They're the most annoying.
And they're fast.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, that was so close.
Holy cow.
Okay.
We're good?
Everything's fine?
Jump, too!
Everything's okay, probably?
Yeah, everything's fine.
Wait.
Yippee!
Oh!
Our...
Our stop.
I'm excited to see what the next...
What's a cult thing is?
The next...
We only have two left on that.
uh little area we build in our shelter because i see the
data the world data thing right there i think i found an rem
yeah rem that's what it's called all right all right
cardinal bound for earth must undergo inspection and be
delivered to the designated warehouse with the proper permit
attached additionally anyone returning to earth must receive
a vital signs check at the central port before meeting oh
the shuttle crew we're infected
so eight is planning to send dead filament to her they're
not gonna let us go she's trying to use the transport like
what if it's automated you know if she succeeds we're out of
a ride
okay I see some cubes delicious cubes delicious yummy yummy
yummy Oh, be careful.
Wait.
Tuna?
My bad.
We're fine.
Tuna?
Wait, did I get it?
Where's my cube at?
I hear him, I hear him.
Oh, that scared me.
Be careful!
It's infected with dead filament!
This crap again!
Ew!
I will cleanse it.
Oh.
Cleanse has the power to remove any traces of dead filament.
The bots are corrupted with dead filament.
I love that we are literally an endgame.
We're like on the last chapter and we're getting new
tutorials.
What is Tuna Chat?
This is a little robot.
That's what it sounds like he's saying.
He goes, Tuna!
to find him and hit him and then it gets added to your
shelter.
All corrupted nodes will disappear from their hacking
matrices, hold LB to use cleanse, and hold it even longer to
unleash a full charge.
Okay.
But hold on.
Very important.
Is it?
Is that our only... Is it only him?
Don't worry.
Come over here.
Psspsspsspsspsspss.
Wait.
Back to normal!
Stupid head!
This sounds like too not...
Wait!
Oh, that's just a sticky bombs.
No.
Oh, there's another guy!
Where did you come from?
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, that's right.
My bad.
Right on.
Uh, wow.
Oh, my God.
I took out the whole floor.
Oh, you're not open.
You're going down.
Burst?
Wait, why is he burst?
Ouch!
Oh, my God.
Wait, I tried to cleanse him.
Holy cow.
That was huge.
there it is I thought I had done it oh my gosh that was like
crazy that guy's gonna bust open we did do that it's kind of
crazy John 6 Bustin, busting, busting, busting.
Wait, let's go back up here and see if we can find Tuna.
I hear him.
Tuna!
Do you guys see him?
Wait, I see him!
Right there.
Nice!
Oh, I was gonna say, where do I go from here?
But I see the red marker.
It's telling me to print stuff.
No!
Nice.
What's gonna happen in there?
There's no, I wish I could charge, I wish I could do a
shockwave gun.
Um, let's heal real quick and then I'll go on.
And ready?
Wah!
Oh,
holy cow, he took so much damage.
Is that it?
Nope.
I wish.
Getting close!
I only got one guy Oh, this sucks He's gonna burst again I
thought I Oh my god Ouch, out, out, out I thought I got at
least You know Like two guys But I got one guide!
Ugh.
More of them?
No, these are the same guys from before.
Oh shoot.
It's so difficult to...
I guess maybe if I'm...
Yeah.
Oh!
What the?!
Yeah, that should have hit!
That should have killed him.
That should have been it.
You... jerk.
Oh,
okay.
Take this!
The shock wave!
Should have, maybe they're just a tiny tad bit stronger.
More?
No, you're kidding me right now.
You're kidding me right now!
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Holy cow!
Please!
Ah!
Oh!
I'm just dodging!
I'm just dodging the whole time!
Oh.
Uh, I'm gonna...
There's his core!
Okay.
Uh, if you turn around?
Oh.
That's his core?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, whoops!
That's not what I meant to do.
This is like the tiniest space ever!
Oh my god.
Are we dead?
No!
Holy cow!
Hugh!
Hugh?
I kept accidentally dodging towards him instead of...
He one hit killed me.
That's crazy.
One shot at me.
What should we do?
Yeah!
I thought they'd never end.
Then I died!
I didn't think, I didn't expect a big baby!
Looks like Ait and Edith are dead south stopping us.
In other words, plus scrap heads means we're on the right
path.
Does that mean more are coming?
It's crazy damage though.
I know!
Holy heck!
But hey, would the new and improved you and me here?
I'm gonna save my thing for, uh...
Yeah!
We'll save my, um, my ult for that guy because otherwise...
I have craziness.
Actual craziness.
Oh, I'm gonna have to go through all that again!
Oh, well.
Um, let's do...
Let's do a repair up.
Hacking gauge.
Delete protocol.
Deletion protocol.
We'll do...
Oh, yeah, because...
I
was thinking the mod slot also.
Multiple mods.
I'll do the mod slot.
We've been kind of going on the little bit amount that we've
gotten.
so all right let's try that again geez louise okay
we'll do heat and confuse maybe would be good multi-hack and
here um shockwave wait i don't have to go through the tram
again do i or oh gosh Where is it going to send me?
I wonder.
Not homing myself.
Shop wave gun.
And homing.
Still there.
And then riot.
But I think we'll also need to use the stasis net.
And like stuff here.
The riot blaster is not at.
Well.
Maybe.
It didn't quite work before.
Hmm.
Impact barrier.
Oh yeah.
I got to remember that.
too that'll be really helpful against against the baby and
now we can add one more mod we shall add there was the one
what was it this one successfully activating EC we get 10%
HP I feel like that might be pretty good what's this one
attack
No drop rate from enemies, 10%.
You see, is like, wait, you see, is that when I do a perfect
dodge?
I think?
Stretcher.
Knockdown recovery.
Oh, it's when you dodge after getting hit.
Oh, oh, that's, I rarely ever succeed in that.
Let's do this one because we're going to be in close
quarters.
We're gonna be in close quarters because we're in this tiny,
the tiniest space ever.
They give you no room to walk around and...
Oh, okay, okay, we're at the cargo terminal.
Okay, good, good, good.
Yes.
Hi, Minky.
Hello.
Pragmatics CQC, pretty much.
Oh, I gotta make use of my, uh...
What's it called?
The, um...
Our weapons that will...
Our defense stuff, like our...
Like our impact barrier.
And things.
Thank you, I will take that.
Wait, where do you go?
Oh, there he is.
Never mind.
He's not fine.
He was fine for two seconds.
What already?
Time for a cleanup.
Yeah.
Alright, and we're charging again.
Oh.
Keep the shooting to me.
Oh!
I'm doing it more again?
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah!
That was cleaner.
This was much cleaner than before.
And we're back to full health.
Like we have all of our everything.
Okay, that was good.
Music is so awesome.
Alright, Stasis Net.
I have, right?
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, now we know what we're dealing with.
Wait, wait, wait!
But what if I don't?
What if after the baby, there's more?
It's a tough level, huh?
What if I can start already?
We need to cleanse them.
Wait, I didn't get a single guy in that.
Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
He was...
He was in my way.
Or I thought he was.
Wait.
I'm still being stupid!
Yay!
And then...
Oh, oh!
I'm really glad I did that!
it's pretty short range it feels very short range okay i'm
still within my thing good good
it's fine we did it charging cleanse we're just gonna sit in
here and do it like crazy
oh let's rt High risk, high reward.
Yeah, I guess so.
Oh, yeah.
He's inside.
We're reloading.
Maybe I can get both?
Yeah!
Oh, I got both!
Like that too!
Nice, nice.
Nice!
Okay, Stasis net.
For impact barrier, I mean.
Okay.
Uh...
What is he doing?
Oh, he's confused!
He's so stupid!
I'm just trying to get him at all!
Oh my god.
Maybe homing missiles?
Oh, he's really tanky.
Wait, is he even open?
No, I'm stupid.
That's my fault.
...
Is he taking any damage?
Stace's net.
Uh, a nun.
He's hot.
He's on fire.
Am I doing anything?
Oh my gosh.
I feel stupid right now.
Like, I feel like I'm relearning the game.
Oh, we have to cleanse it!
Oh my god, you guys are so right.
oh she's still on cool down right right right i'm so stupid
i'm so stupid i'm so stupid i'll take care of it okay
oh good good good okay
Everything's fine.
We made it.
I was a little dumb about it.
I forgot the cleanse entirely.
I don't know why.
Sorry.
I don't know why I forgot the cleanse.
Ouchie, ouch.
What is that?
Okay.
Is this more sticky bombs?
Yeah.
We did it though.
We're okay.
That took so much of my everything.
I could really use some more.
Under the right conditions.
What is her end goal?
Maybe she's sad that...
Maybe 8 is the one who, you know, is upset that she was
treated as, you know, just, like, daisies.
I peeked at Jacob's terminal the other day, and it looks
like the higher-ups are worried about some kind of black
substance.
I couldn't make out all the details, but I did catch
fragments.
organic matter and something about potential nationwide
impact.
In other words, a dangerous black substance has been found
that Dr. Higgins can't even handle and it's bad enough to
melt the entire US.
No, wait.
US?
The world?
Maybe?
Nationwide?
International?
No way, right?
Maybe I've just been playing too many survival horror games.
Right.
just the u.s she's using dead filament these dang americans
yeah i don't think she cares so much about just the u.s i
think she's gonna take out everybody
transfer dead filament designated payload is at 70 percent
oh that's no good i'm gonna activate this and then
everybody's gonna come jump in a board Is there anything
else I could grab?
I missed something.
ABS you guys always...
Look at the filaments!
Look, you can see them being transported.
Wow!
Oh, goopy.
Whoa!
She really dislikes burgers.
This game really is so good looking.
I almost wish I had played it on my PS5 so I could have it
at like the highest settings.
enough
Wow are
we moving or oh yes we are we're going down you look what
that black stuff that's all dead filament that box it must
have come in from all over the cradle oh that much crap
never reaches earth came over i'm over
over you still look for this you'll be there too this place
is huge how are we gonna get in there oh we're infected
though Diana it's over it's jover for us oh we made it but
it's not a straight shot to the orbital elevator is it looks
like we'll have to go through that building head for the
orbital elevator this building to go to that building.
Oh.
Oh, this is a red room key.
We haven't... I feel like I've only seen two, one or two of
these.
And training data.
I haven't been doing anything.
I'm sorry.
I am gonna head back so I can recuperate my supplies.
And then we'll immediately come back.
I didn't take much damage, but I lost, like, all of my
weapons.
Fighting those guys.
It's not mint over till the Ibu sings.
What would you sing?
Sing.
Sing a song.
What could he simply bring back this time?
We brought back.
Wait, I do have six cubes.
We could upgrade.
Yeah, I agree, Diana.
It's worthy of clapping.
Evermore?
I know she'll never leave me.
Oh no.
Why does that feel like a song?
I could feel like, you know, biscuit.
Wait, did we, no, that's it.
Weapon loadout, shockwave, and homing missiles, and stasis
net, riot buster, and impact the barrier and multi-hack and
confuse and hate i like the confuse
oh wait i'm also gonna switch out my mods we don't
necessarily need the close quarters one anymore so let's see
what else we could get chargeable weapons charge 30 faster
Hacking gauge buildup by 15% When successfully completing a
hack Increases hacking node duration by 20% Increases
hacking damage by 10% But weapon damage No, I don't want
that one
Like part of me is like Chargeable weapons What else is like
LB Is all also chargeable?
Your birthday merch finally came in Everything turned out
fantastic Here's to another year of you, Minky Stories,
thank you I'm so sorry that We all didn't realize that it
would take so long.
Setsuna has kind of said, like, you know, my merch, my
birthday merch drop was kind of like, uh, I was the guinea
pig, in a sense, for how these things kind of operate.
Um, but hopefully in the future, merch doesn't take nearly
as long.
But yeah, they were really good about updating, I think,
during, it all.
What does it mean increases hacking node duration?
Oh, like the nodes.
Just kidding.
I know what that means.
Hyper focus.
Direct hits from enemies no longer reset the hacking matrix.
That's kind of nice.
I got an update a couple of hours ago.
Oh, that's awesome.
It almost took a year.
I know.
I'm so sorry.
Well.
It's still May.
September, October.
Five months!
That's not almost a year.
But I get what you mean.
Recursive learning.
This is how I can get a little...
Oh, we could do our HP!
Let's just do that until I figure out what else I want to
do.
Research Sector Gate.
It's been nine years.
I'm still waiting mine, not even a note from the shop app.
Well, things are getting packed.
So maybe the shop app is like...
We'll update once it's shipped.
If not, you can always email and ask the status.
I give you permission to bug them as much as you want.
This sector manages priority projects associated with
proposals submitted to Earth HQ.
sensitive nature of these projects all access is
continuously logged attention for entry to the luna filament
lab obtain clearance via the secretary's office everybody's
telling me to go to the secretary she must be high why am i
assuming it's a she oh bad brain
whoa i can't cleanse this why why not
Oh, come on.
Oh, shoot.
I'm dead.
Where are we?
Wait, where am I?
What?
Uh.
Wait, where am I?
It, like, transported me.
I think it assumed that I touched...
Maybe...
I guess I some... Oh, no.
But I want that.
Wait.
I guess it saw that I touched the wall.
Okay, hold on.
Yeah, put me forward.
Ouch!
We can do this.
Oh, now!
Now!
That's so funny.
Now it puts me back.
Oh, okay.
I thought it was one of those that, like...
That does it multiple times, multiple hits.
But it was not at all.
That's why I was, like, a little freaked out about it.
But I want to go up here.
So that we can get that.
It put me, like, completely where I needed to be.
That's so funny.
Cabin coin!
Cabin will love that.
Give me, give me, and give me.
Very nice.
Oh.
Sound like something's happening.
We're good.
We're all good now.
My bad, Diana.
Oh, my bad.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Shit,
shit, shit.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Oh wait, I need to...
Okay.
We're going crazy mode.
We're gonna go crazy mode.
Get a little closer.
Cleanse up to three or more enemies at a time!
Yeah, rough spot to be for sure.
Oh shoot.
Wait, uh...
I got an achievement for it.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
That's okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to do it again!
Woo!
Does it need to be cleansed again?
Yeah, it does.
That's annoying.
That's so annoying.
You're assuming a major.
Your job, Kenny.
Ew!
Whoop!
Ouch!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, whatever.
We can still...
We can still get it.
He's gone, great shit.
I was just trying to kill him, man.
I was just trying to get his butt.
Ugh.
Oh!
This one's different!
Be careful!
What do you mean this one's different?
Uh...
Diane, you okay?
Yeah.
Wait, oh there it is.
No, stop!
Oh wait, they're on this back too.
Nice!
Look at that with you!
Uh...
I thought this...
The net would work!
Ah!
That's so mean!
Yeah, yikes.
Yikes indeed.
Oh, shoot.
I went the wrong way.
Oh my god.
This guy is so evil.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
No!
Oh my gosh.
I need to heal again.
Stacy's net!
Okay, run.
Uh...
Get ready!
We're almost there, almost there!
Please!
Ah!
There we go.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
My goodness!
Hey, is it safe for you to clear out all this blood stuff?
I'm okay!
I'm just breaking it up.
Holy cow!
We got another impact barrier at least.
That's great.
Thank you.
Thank you, game.
Holy cow!
I thought we were done for real.
I thought that was it for us.
Oh, it's down here.
some stuff
yeah nice find me nice find what does she lots of money yeah
a lot of limb
there we go no damage taken absolutely none the cleanest run
you've ever seen can i go back home i have like nothing on
me can there please be a ladder oh there is a ladder again
we can't go this way can you get rid of this stuff maybe if
we can get it at the source Does it want us to go this way?
Cleanse the filament at its source.
Okay, hold on.
Before we do that, let's check over here as well.
Oh, it wants us to go this way.
Interesting.
This place sucks.
It does, right?
Oh.
Wow, this is like...
Oh, wow.
Okay.
This is giving me memories of like the first levels.
Oh.
Yahoo!
Hmm, what's in here?
More lore stuff, I imagine?
Oh, we can't go in?
Well, what's on the other side?
Okay, hold on.
Again, sorry, we're returning to the shelter.
I gotta re- I gotta recuperate my weapons.
We're jumping?
No, I thought the laser was gonna come all the way to the
end of the hallway.
That's why I jumped.
Oh, sweet, sweet green.
I'm okay!
We're fine.
Everything's A-okay.
Don't even sweat it.
We expanded our stamp board collection.
More simulations.
Thank you.
Um, I'm just gonna open up this one.
Cradle infiltration log day four.
Wait, oh.
You have quite the honor.
Thank you, cabin.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
was a bit of a gauntlet back there for here suddenly a new
guy after after evil mutated baby
okay change of plans the sourcing can wait oh it's this
person again i've defined decided to focus on the facility
itself i'll check every inch of this place staff tunnels
storage maintenance ducks you name it there has to be
something i missed i just need to be careful the last thing
I need is to bring attention to myself, having my legs
hanging out from the air duct.
Yeah, mutated baby and noodle arms.
Everything was crazy.
I believe it's in my best interest to search the staff's
private quarters as thoroughly as possible.
A few folks here have invited me back to their rooms, but I
can't exactly go rummaging through their belongings right in
front of them.
I'll look into forging a biometric tag.
If any luck, it'll bypass the locks.
I have a question.
I just realized does shooting the spikes after you purify
it, does that stop it from corrupting again?
I just had that thought.
So you shoot the spikes.
It causes it so it can't purify.
Okay, re-corrupt and then you can shoot the weakness on the
back.
Got it.
Thank you guys.
Alright, it worked.
The tags copied and loaded.
Now I can come and go as a place.
snuck into a room of a Terra Dome worker.
Let's see.
What little treasures might be tucked away in here?
Well, well, would you look at that?
A tablet and a draft email, no less.
Experimental pragmatics, access is currently restricted.
Request to lift the restriction is underway.
Experimental pragmatics.
Funny, I didn't find that listed on the tram map.
I'm gonna have to get some water real soon.
Well, I'll be damned.
So this is where that unmarked tram line leads.
I'll chat with some staff later and try to figure out what's
really going on here.
The last stage is such a difficulty jump.
If... I don't want to, but if it becomes a little too
frustrating, I might change the difficulty.
We'll see.
Just because I'm feeling so slippery today.
Let's do more Stasis Net because I'm using it more often
now.
Max active.
Yeah, we'll do that too.
We're very close to the end.
Great job, Minto.
What's your fave level?
I like the green one.
I like the green one, too.
That was good.
I like the green one.
I think the mining was kind of fun because of the new like
gravity element of it all.
That was kind of fun.
No, wait.
Yeah.
Homing missiles.
I don't even know if homing missiles are that good but i
just keep using them because homing i don't have to i don't
have to aim stasis net riot blaster in fact yeah um confused
heat and multi-hack okay honestly i think having the extra
health saved my booty too i thought the weird messed up city
was it honestly the weird messed up city like really set the
uh tone of the game right where you're like whoa this place
is massive and something truly is going crazy here because
like the city was all like you know warped and everything
the city made me want a barbecue bed barbecue burger bed
yeah the city was really really cool let's see what's going
on in here
stopping us from doing anything.
Oh, Cradle Logistics Network Overview.
This project began with early lunar development to transport
processed lunar filament and other essential materials.
By sliding designated containers through a network of pipes
spanning the cradle, we established a low-cost rapid
transport system.
Oh my gosh, it's like a transport shinkansen.
Transport bullet train.
NASA started a project for a moon base?
Now Pragmata can be real.
The Luna Filament!
No, transporting people or living organisms inside these
containers is strictly prohibited due to safety concerns.
So that's how it's moving everything around so fast.
Oh.
We don't have much time.
Oh shoot.
Yeah!
Take this!
And... next one?
Oh.
He's not dead, just kidding.
Oh my god.
I got him.
I almost didn't get him.
That was kind of scary for a second there.
Ouch, ouch.
Can we get through here?
Is there a...
Yes!
Got it!
That one was spooky, slippery guy.
I know.
Tuna?
I hear him.
Cabin coin.
There he is.
Why can't I aim?
Oh gosh.
Bingo!
Wait, why can't I get into this one?
Oh.
gamers don't look up that was close nice heat transfer enemy
heat it just feels 10% faster causing enemies to be downed
more quickly oh that one's not bad scary when they're
overheated yeah so true cool we just cleared that area very
easy very good very nice Nice.
She looked up!
I can't believe my gamer looked up.
Look, the city is kind of here too.
Yeah, you got the cars and stuff.
We're back in the city.
And actually, it's everything.
We have...
We have basketball!
And we have trees.
Like, everything is all combined here.
It's freaky.
Tree!
Okay, how do I do this now?
Okay, it does end right there.
Oh, you can open this again.
Oh, it was in here?
Oh, okay.
Oh, golly.
What the hell is this?
I wonder if I just...
Ouch!
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Please let me leave.
Pop-scotch.
First try.
Red.
I'm scared of any red zone this point forward.
This far in the game?
Terrifying.
I can't handle all of this.
Don't worry.
I'll get us through.
There's so much goop.
I hope the game is at least generous in that like there's a
ton of goop but there's a little less enemies.
They might be tougher but like it's going to be really hard
maneuvering around all of this while like fighting 15 super
strong guys.
You know what I mean?
So I'm kind of nervous about that!
Oh my god.
Uh.
That was crazy.
That was so close!
Ah!
Oh my god, please.
He's confused, he's confused.
He's not confused.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
It's like, please use your...
Your overdrive is like telling you.
I think I can kill him here.
Yeah, he's confused.
He's confused.
It's okay.
If I could at least shoot him.
Holy cow.
Yeah, we might need to start ulting, like, just immediately.
Not immediately, but, you know.
Not being so conservative with it.
Because.
Otherwise, I'm gonna die.
For realsie.
Oh!
Can I clean this?
Better to ult too soon than die.
So true.
Oh.
Good.
That's really tough.
Like, if I touch this, am I good?
Okay, this is good.
It's just the purple goop.
Just making sure.
Just purple goop.
I missed a secret wall.
I'll have to go back in, huh?
Okay.
What was that?
Oh, I grabbed something, but I'm not quite sure what.
Photon laser?
Is this the way I'm supposed to go?
Hold on.
I wanna get up there.
Also, secret wall.
Is it one of these?
Oh, I see it, I see it!
Thank you.
I was wondering how to get this.
Whoa, we're going to the beach!
Exciting!
Galactic, welcome back.
Thank you!
Entachi, welcome back.
I wonder what that is.
Important notice.
It came!
I finally got the notice granting me level 6 access and a
work transfer to experimental pragmatics.
In other words, Dr. Higgins' lab.
That's fine and dandy, but the notice also documented all of
my hidden rooms and all the walls!
Was this their way of telling me to cut it out?
It doesn't say that outright, but I've heard the new
management AI they're rolling out will require a bio link
for every staff member.
I guess my fun with the hollow walls is coming to an end.
But all of this has me wondering, what if I'm being watched
right now?
Either way, I've got a week to reply to the transfer notice.
Should I go for it?
Sharon.
What do you mean, Sharon's the worst?
She's so good.
She's so funny.
She's so funny,
though.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, it really does feel like the difficulty in this like,
went overdrive all of a sudden.
Am I- is this the way I'm supposed to go?
I think it's a mod.
Might be good to have.
Let's go check it out.
Maybe?
I can't tell.
Oh!
Oh, six upgrades.
Let's go.
It's Edis.
Calculate the potential risks.
Intervention by cradle personnel at 87% probability.
That's us.
Oh!
You understood.
No!
Eight, why?
First eight, I forced Edis to kill everyone.
Whoa.
Eight, why?
Okay, let's go downstairs and explore that one area real
quick and then we'll come back.
If the difficulty is overdrive, then so should you.
Okay.
It was here, yeah.
Spooky area.
Very spooky, scary.
What could be down here?
Hopefully something good.
Hopefully something that I want.
Hopefully.
Something good?
Oh.
Um.
I'm looking at that gigantic hole.
in the ground and that oh there's another hole I don't know
about that one oh
I oh and it's even locked it's locked by I have to defeat
them you know so anyway Let's continue the game.
Gotta get them all, right?
Diana's forcing me to 100% the game.
She's like, come on, Hugh.
You gotta get them all.
At least it's not a giant worm this time.
I don't know.
We now have rubber arm guy, though.
I kind of wish...
I didn't mind the worm so much.
Compared to that guy.
What is this?
Coffee?
What can we print?
Sikima, okay.
I only have three health, so I'm a little nervous.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, uh-oh.
It's charging down.
Are they gonna transform?
Oh, that didn't do anything to that guy.
Oh, shoot.
Holy cow!
I was just climbing up!
Please!
Oh shoot, my god.
Um, um...
Oh, is that guy too?
Holy cow!
Okay, I'm ulting.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm almost dead.
Let's kill this guy while we're at it.
Oh, I didn't, I don't know why I did that.
We need to cleanse who?
Oh, shoot.
Ah,
I don't think I was close enough.
Oh,
my God, please.
This is, this is actually, this is, this is.
What is happening?
is actually insane this is this is unfair this is unfair
don't
forget your other weapons I died but yeah you're right I was
just so overwhelmed what the hell was that didn't realize
how tough this was without decoy maybe I should do decoy
instead of the the barrier hmm yeah this is that's that's
actually impossible sort of like assistance though.
Oh, we almost had it.
I don't think we did.
Wait, hold on, I have something for you.
The beach.
I can't believe Aedis attack all the people at the cradle.
I know.
That one was crazy.
Okay.
Yeah, now that I know how in actually insane it gets, I
will, uh, um, yeah.
Yippee!
Now I've got a weapon too!
Oh, yeah.
That became actual insanity.
Let's go to the beach.
Yeah, I need a...
I need a...
Actually, we can bingo.
And Peter bought.
I'm sick of these dang bots.
Reduces damage received by 20% for 20 seconds after using a
repair cartridge.
Oh, that's good enough.
What did we get?
Oh, a new...
That looks like a health thing.
Hacking node that uses enemy processing power to boost Hues
suit efficiency, restoring a small amount of HP!
Passing through multiple nodes of the same type increases
recovery!
Whoa!
Nice.
I will be stealing that.
Please enjoy your purchase.
the decoy the decoy is pretty broken actually i think i have
it maxed even don't i
oh wait i didn't realize i already had it unlocked oops
whatever um yes my decoy is all the way max i mean so is my
barrier but yeah decoy octopus all right let's see this is
so crazy and we'll just we'll just stand there while they
attack the decoy and then we'll like load the cleansing and
then plowy on the big guys
i yeah i wish that the guys would it looks like the thing
just kind of counts down it doesn't give you a chance to
like kill them and then it generates new enemies like the
lasers like countdown and then it brings new enemies it's
super duper whack okay shit transfer oh wait I forgot my
hacking notes Q and multi hack and confused I think would be
best for this one riot gun helps too yeah I I was, like I
said, I was just so overwhelmed that...
I couldn't... I was so overwhelmed, I couldn't even process
what was happening.
Okay.
Aw, man.
The bots with dead filament on them have extra bad nodes
that make hacking harder.
Aww.
It should be easier if I cleanse them first.
That's all you.
No!
Aw, man.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
My bad, Diana.
Oh, my bad.
My bad in general.
Ouch!
My bad.
Clean.
Don't worry about it.
These guys are probably back, right?
There's a...
Guy that needs to be cleansed over on this side.
Uh...
Sure.
Okay.
We'll get this guy real quick.
Alright!
And then...
Okay!
Now just one guy left.
You!
Oh, oh, oh, ouch.
Actually, I don't want to... Come on!
Where are you?
Nope.
Please.
Ooyayayayay!
Wait, was he...
Un...
Yeah.
Oops, my bad.
I think I was shooting at him and I was doing nothing.
Please!
Screw you.
Okay.
We didn't lose nearly as much health as last time.
So, sometimes it just takes a second view over, you know?
Wait, can I get this stuff again in here?
No.
Lank.
Okay.
Alright.
Hoi.
My Ryden is showing.
What does that mean?
This area is so scary.
Oh gosh.
Okay, decoy gun.
Wait, I don't want to waste it.
The first guys are like babies.
I just have to take them out fast.
Let me go get some water.
Be right back.
I grabbed water and went for a bathroom and I also grabbed a
snack.
Welcome back, thank you!
One second.
What did you get?
For snack?
Caramel.
Caramel candy.
Welcome back, thank you!
I don't remember even if I need it for this.
Oh wait, I don't think so.
Okay.
Decoy!
I just have to.
Or else I'll die.
I got him!
Please!
Watch out!
I
like this!
Okay.
Oh, cleanse him!
Charging!
Charging who?
Who are we cleansing?
Oh, those guys.
Okay.
All right.
Take that guy out!
Okay.
Nice double, thank you.
Oh geez, this guy is still available.
We're alive, I mean.
That's why it was.
Holy cow, okay.
Okay, we're gonna cleanse him.
this guy ultra okay wait he's not confused oh shit oh shit
oh shit oh shit okay uh we need to confuse them a bit more
maybe i don't know who i just did that too
okay hold on let's grab that guy i missed out on ultra
cleanse but Whatever.
Uh...
I'm so scared right now.
Oh, it's not doing like anything.
Um, charge piercer maybe.
Oh god, I'm so dead.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Uh...
Okay.
I wish I had more decoy!
Hey!
Oh, I need to cleanse him, right?
Please.
Ah!
Yeah, all crap is real.
Fuck now, man.
It's time to hide!
Oh!
Overdrive.
Yes.
You're going down.
All right.
Now you're just a baby.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that overdrive did like numbers.
Oh, thank God.
Ah!
I thought you were gonna be dead.
I thought you were a dead man.
Oh, he was just down, I think.
Look, I didn't even have to heal.
Yippee.
That was scary.
It's a really tough room.
It is a tough room, isn't it?
Holy cow.
Wait a second.
You've been here the whole time?
You've been here.
here the whole time you son of a gun sure i'll just take
anything at this point oh more stuff ow don't worry about it
please give me an elevator after all that we found the
source oh crap really
pure lunum
what's going on over here though oh i'm just i'm on top of
it i'm on top of it again can i go through here yet no okay
it wants me to purify you used your resources awesomely
thank you
i'm glad we got through that i hope did it save i don't i
didn't check the corner if it auto saved after that i sure
hope it did the way forward should be clear
Head to eight.
Head for the orbital elevator.
Oh wait, there's our...
There's our...
Okay.
I'm going...
I don't care.
I'm going back to the shelter.
I know I'm not that hurt.
Again, we recoup our supplies.
There we go.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
I'm so hungry.
Can't wait to finish the game.
Wanna check if we can upgrade anything?
I do wanna check if we can upgrade anything!
We're gonna upgrade.
You know what?
I will upgrade my suit.
At this point, I think I need the more health.
Okay, cool.
And we can upgrade something else here.
Maybe our...
Deletion Protocol?
I feel like we'll be using it more often?
Huh.
Food break?
No, it's okay.
That's why I had the, um, the caramel.
We're a hacking gauge.
The hacking gauge buildup will allow us to use deletion
protocol more.
Or we could save for more thrusters or more repair.
What's your favorite cuisine, Minto?
I like American Chinese.
I love American Chinese.
I don't blame you one bit.
Oh, this is the impeter.
I can't hack it if it zaps me.
I'm sesame chicken.
I could go for some sweet and sour.
That's my go-to choice.
Uh, no, we'll do shockwave and you is home.
and you is riot blaster and stasis net and you is impact
barrier we'll keep impact the barrier for now a little
something to go towards a nice dinner oh no takizo you don't
have to do that thank you for the really fun streams it's
been an oasis for me through some rough times i hope you
guys don't have tough times i know that it has to happen but
i wish it didn't have to happen but i'm glad that i can at
least speak you know, a constant maybe of just streaming for
you guys.
Tough times never last.
Only tough people last.
That's the wise words.
I kind of want to try Taco Bell right now after hearing so
much about it in these streams.
Frizznom, I've never had...
The Statue of Blue!
Liberty!
Oh,
this is where we came through.
I was curious.
A statue of Liberty.
These are real Metal Gear Hours.
Oh, I don't like the way this looks.
I hope we're not too late to stop 8.
Don't worry.
Red room.
Red room is what I do best.
A little trouble is all part of the job.
Are we a janitor?
Trees.
I see.
Oh, there's a...
That's another ladder.
this door is locked too let me guess ah more terminals yeah
oh my gosh
let's pick our poison oh parkour we'll go we'll no we'll go
the tougher one first take this keyboard
Oh Watch this oh no don't watch that
Wait aren't they supposed to be confused
Get confused get confused.
There we go get confused get confused.
It's my turn get confused get confused.
Oh shoot Oh,
it's all on him I wish the heat engage went up like Bastard?
You know what I mean?
Yeah!
Oh, huge.
Actually, I should probably start attacking him, huh?
Oh, holy cow!
No, you.
I don't remember where his weak point is.
Okay, uh...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Sorry, I'm not locked in right now.
I totally screwed that up.
There we go.
I'll just get rid of one guy.
You.
Where is your weak point?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's down there.
It's your pee-pee.
Let
me...
The booty, booty hole, booty hole, booty hole.
Is it his pee-pee?
Yeah.
Oh, closer.
Closer, closer, closer.
Kinda ballsy.
Oh, maybe we can get him?
He's kind of slow.
I just realized what room this is.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, look out!
Wait, I just realized what room this is.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, wait, can I...
Yes!
I was like, what are these things on the floor?
I forgot!
I was like, can I not walk on them?
I just remembered!
I was wondering if those floor tiles did anything.
Yes!
Oh, that was the perfect time to use it.
Thank goodness I remembered right at the perfect time!
Ah, perfect timing!
That was so good!
That was so good, actually.
Holy cow.
Um, yeah.
Nice.
We love to see that.
Hmm.
Oh.
What the hell?
It's breaking in!
Is that them on the floor?
Oh my god, it's him on the floor!
This black stuff is all that's left...
Did the dead fellowman eat them?
That's why we haven't seen any people!
Fighting ghosts, fighting his demons.
Diana, think you can cleanse infected humans?
Oh no, once their cells get eaten, in the way, they're gone
for good.
Uh-oh.
Don't tell Hugh that.
I see.
There's nothing you can do.
This explains why there's so much dead filament.
It ate everybody.
Oh my god.
It ate them all.
That's why we haven't seen any bodies.
That's freaky.
Yeah, all the The suit's on the floor!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what's down there versus what's up here?
Uh-oh.
Boy.
Oh, can't wait.
I don't see things on the floor that activate some guys, but
it might still happen.
Confidential Delphi information.
The residents became food.
It's painful!
As you know, Daisy Higgins, Dr. Higgins' daughter, has
passed away.
The truth is her death was not caused by illness.
Dr. Higgins had been running a clinical trial on a luna
filament compound using Pragmata, and the outcomes were more
than encouraging, so he reported his findings to Earth HQ.
Then one of the higher-ups, Adelphi, attempted to claim
credit and pushed prematurely into human testing for
commercialization.
Their subordinates were instructed to select a test subject
whose data matched Daisy's age, sex, and medical history,
and the compound was administered.
However, Pragmata cannot perfectly replicate human
physiology.
The formula remained unstable and was far ready for human
use.
Dr. Higgins issued repeated warnings, but no one listened.
No wonder...
So maybe he really did make eight to, like, go...
Crazy in mode.
Again, if my daughter can't live, nobody can.
The chosen subject died immediately after the injection.
Only afterward did they realize it was Daisy, Dr. Higgins'
daughter.
The executive who ordered it silenced all witnesses to bury
the truth.
This was clearly corporate murder.
A preventable tragedy.
I only recently heard the story from a first-hand source.
While I'm confirmed, it's probably true.
With the bots running amok now, I can't help thinking this
is Delphi's karma.
Mistake after mistake has brought us here.
So Delphi.
Delphi.
Sorry.
Just covered it up.
Umbrella core all over again, right?
Mm-hmm.
Disgusting!
Wait, let's go downstairs first.
There might be some stuff down here.
Including guys.
Probably.
Yeah.
Cool.
Wait, is this where I'm supposed to go?
Actually, I can't...
No, I don't think so, but...
Oh.
Oh, I'm on the other side!
Haven't gone!
Fun to collect!
I know, right?
Honey!
Okay, that should be everything in here.
Unless?
I think so.
Alright, cool.
Okay, spooky room incoming.
Oh, that was a...
That was good info, though.
That was some crazy info, actually.
I'm trying...
I'm peeking in here to see what's going on.
Um, I'm scared.
Are we just playing hop?
Oh, fuck.
Of course.
No!
My ultra charge!
You bastard!
Yeah, I'll take everybody out.
Even you.
This is my turn.
Yeah, I'll take everybody out.
All right.
That's one core down.
Stupid Avenue!
Yeah, you!
I wish I could get its weak point.
I guess I could remove.
There we go.
maybe he'll the heat gauge will go crazy no no he's stupid
there it is
yeah why can they ignore the laser so true oh he's still
alive no he's dead sorry him lying dead on the floor she
still left what's that that's a photon laser we'll take you
very good thank you very much bye bye bye bye wait
yep let's wrap this up don't want to keep her waiting oh i
have to go back my bad
Maybe them and the lasers are in cahoots?
Probably.
I believe it.
Wait.
Well, luckily it's not that far of a way back.
Oh, you guys!
Rip in peace, rip in peace.
You poor bastards.
What was this again?
Sticky bombs.
Actually, well, I was...
I'm like, do I go back so that I can have the same...
save so i don't have to do that side again i can't i'm sure
it saved once i did that one oh i see the other do i also go
back so i can heal again yeah we'll check it out we'll see
oh sorry my bad my bad
whoa it's just parkour you've got to be kidding me this
one's locked too there should be some turrets
Oh, I was preemptively.
Hoi!
Hi!
I can't see it too!
I think it's over 65!
Good dude!
That makes two!
Okay.
Well, I couldn't tell if there was a guy who became active
or not.
Hmm.
Um...
I hear I hear a cabin Thank you so much for the attack Thank
you What's that?
Oh, data shard Okay, thank you Actually, I'll take that for
real
Wait Wait Wait Wait Wait Wait, what's that noise Holy cow
Oh, shoot Wait.
I'll take some health from you, thank you very much.
Hey, we're back, thank you for the gifted.
What's up, what's happening?
Why are we gift to go this way then?
Why is everybody gift to go this way then?
Wait.
Okay, this will unlock some more guys.
One more to go.
Got it.
Right?
You're sure the last one's in here?
Yeah, I'm picking up a signal nearby.
Okay, maybe not.
Ouch.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Nice and big.
We got him.
We missed all the action.
Where am I anyway?
Sorry.
I'm getting greedy.
I'm busy, yeah.
I'm busy.
Ouch.
Sorry.
My bad.
Is
there a way to not become corrupted, I wonder?
Like, if I never touch the goop ever.
Perfect game.
Good end.
It'll still be a good end.
Right, guys?
Still...
Found it.
We did it!
Too locked in to notice my gamer Vtuber.
Wait, what did I... Oh, I got raided!
Wait.
I got raided?
Wait, who raided?
Callie!
Hi, Callie!
Wait, hi, deadbeats!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so lost!
Sorry.
I'm a gamer.
Hi, everybody!
Hello, hi, deadbeats!
Wait, Callie, thank you so much for that raid that wreck.
I really appreciate it.
Wait, that was a solid five minutes.
Okay, to be fair, though.
To be fair, on my end, used to be at the very top.
I don't know how it looks for you guys, but it used to be at
the top in white, and now they're on the bottom in black,
and it blends in with the... It blends in with the chat.
I was pretty locked in, though.
Hi, I'm at the end of Pragmata.
I'm about to... I think I'm about to beat it soon-ish, so...
Maybe it is spoilers.
It's still on top for you.
Yeah, it's not for me It's pretty icky.
Wanna...
One of those lame...
One of those lame things that they decided to update for no
darn good reason.
Delicious health.
Gamer Girl 2 locked in the notice the literal grim reaper at
her doorstep.
Okay, to be fair, do I need to worry about a grim reaper at
my doorstep anymore?
I'm a dead ghost!
I'm literally dead!
I don't need to worry...
The grim reaper got me!
Ow!
Oh my god!
Don't take me to the afterlife!
You call that a sand castle?
Become beach royalty with your own castle of sand.
How will you decorate yours?
Designated painting is at 80%.
Not 80%.
Let's hurry, Diana!
Oh no.
I've got your back!
No!
Wait, what?
Tough room?
Oh no.
Guys, I don't know what to expect.
This game is really hard though.
At least this last level has gotten pretty scary.
I have my impact barrier.
I won't waste it immediately.
I will try not to waste.
Okay.
You got this, you made it this far.
It's really just the unexpected that scares me.
I don't want to have to unlock that door all over again.
Here we go!
What if I just activated it?
Oh.
We don't have time for this.
Charge Mega Charge!
Wait!
Oh, I have to wait for her to reload.
Charge!
Mega!
Let's charge!
Die!
Like, yeah.
Oh, take that.
Yeah, for sure.
What else we got?
Oh, my gosh.
No.
Oh, no.
Wait, did he...
Did he both?
Oh, wait.
He's all bad.
Ah!
Actually.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
Did he just knock him over?
Friendly fire?
Missile spotted.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, please get me out of the pink.
Oh, it's one of these.
Oh my god.
Wait, oh my god.
This is...
This is nuts.
Okay, um...
Be careful.
Ouch, ouch.
I'm trying...
I'm trying to just kill that one guy.
Him.
Literally him!
I'm just trying to kill him right now.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot the floating round thing!
Okay.
Floating round things.
No, no, no!
No missile!
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Right back at ya!
Yeah!
Okay.
I'm gonna impact barrier.
Impact barrier, please.
Sorry.
I'm getting overwhelmed again.
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Getcha!
Are you down?
Yeah, you stupid head.
I'm almost done with him.
Hopefully that's it.
Oh, you.
Please, nothing, nothing happened while I'm...
Oh my god, please.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
Let's actually get back into my barrier.
That's a good idea.
Please be everything.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
Yeah!
That one wasn't so bad, actually.
Compared to the other one.
That other one was just so brutal.
All right.
Let's head back.
Yay!
Nice suit.
Good job, team.
Oh.
Oh, there you are.
I'll take the training data.
Thank you, Cabin.
Sorry.
Can't wait to try that in training, Sim.
Wait, where are we?
Actually.
Oh, I'm back in here.
Okay.
Wait.
Did I get everything?
Well, probably not, but...
It's okay.
We will go back and replenish.
Straight in the corruption.
Heal.
And we can give her...
We can give her the delicious sandcastle.
Sorry.
I'm like, save sandcastle!
I can't believe Daisy died.
Aiden and I were made to help her get better.
and the tests worked but that just got her killed hey now
don't get down on yourself what happened to Daisy is not
your fault yeah they messed up the readings that's on down
yeah blinded by short term profits yeah they made the wrong
call over yeah over yeah this ain't on you not even close
got it okay that's so messed up though she she you know for
all we know she could have been getting better And then they
were like, oh, experimental trial on this child.
Here you go.
I'm gonna eat some veggie chips.
I hope that's okay.
I've been mulling it over.
Why?
Manda y'all.
Manda y 'all did.
Yeah.
The souls and the choices you make for yourself.
Don't forget that, okay?
I won't you.
Thanks.
What do you want to do when you get hurt?
Let her talk while I...
I know.
How about you?
First, I'll head home and thank my neighbors for taking care
of things while I was gone.
Then I'll ask them if I can take their scruffy little mud
out for a walk.
Can I come too?
I've never met a scruffy little mud before.
Yeah, a scruffy little mud!
But could you keep that nickname to yourself, please?
All the flags are flying, you guys.
What do you want to do when you get to Earth?
Here's your sandcastle!
What?
Why
would you build something so fragile?
It's just like humans.
So we have a playground, we have a bedroom, we have a
camping site, and we have...
Let's have the beach.
The beach, beach?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did these come from?
She's learning to swim!
She's got her knee pads on and everything!
She's safety first!
I don't like sad.
It's rough and coarse and gets everywhere.
Oh, I don't think we have enough.
We do have enough to upgrade here.
I can't believe how cute she is.
Also, hey, Diana's...
Stop it.
You can't compare me to Diana.
upgrade our shockwave gun because I have been using it a
bunch and the damage needs to go up I think but also we're
gonna do can we do both wait but then my hacking get let's
do my hacking gauge and
deletion protocol no thrusters thrusters oh Oh, I can do us
a delicious protocol!
BAM!
Yeah, baby.
Cabin, I have some- We've expanded our stamp board coverage.
Yes, yes, shh, shh.
Give me my stamp.
Wait, I don't have enough for bingo.
No!
I wish I could see what's in the lock section without having
to- They need to make it more enticing, like, this is what
you get.
Like, they show you, but then they don't show you at the
same time, you know?
Oh, I imagine this one to be complete, completely red.
That's not that bad.
I believe there was a mention of wearing child-sized shoes
earlier, so a comparison might be more apt than you like.
Hey, they're cheaper!
If you could also buy child-sized shoes, wouldn't you also
do it?
The last shot of non-primary units deals 50% more damage.
Oh.
You have quite the eye organ.
Secret Report 5!
Day 5!
Oh, I want to see.
This is one of our more popular items.
Satisfaction level.
Maximum.
Glad we could be of assistance.
Thank you.
Oh, wrong thing.
Not bad.
Oop.
Birth of Edith.
It turns out the Terra Dome works whose tablet I checked
never came back to the room last night.
Guess everyone's favorite overnight shift is to blame?
No big deal.
I left a note on their door.
Hopefully they'll see it when they return.
Please be advised that Edis will begin regular operations
starting 10 today.
Wonder what that announcement was about.
Maybe it's related to that new management AI that they were
testing?
Great.
Just what I need.
A new AI breathing down my neck.
Hopefully this won't cause me any headaches.
Cabin, you say every item is more popular.
I don't know.
That's because he only keeps bangers.
Everything is great.
Better play it safe.
Keep my files on a physical drive and carry it with me.
Worst case scenario, the files are flagged and confiscated.
And all my work goes down the drain.
Shit, I messed up.
While poking around, I accidentally broke one of the
replicators in the commons area.
The power was off, so I plugged it in.
But my dumbass left the power diagnostic meter connected.
You could probably guess, but it shorted out and fried the
emitter.
to a crisp i'm lucky no one saw me guess i'll have to use
the terminal in the shelter
had a word with someone who knows how security works around
here turns out edis is eavesdropping analyzing every single
conversation cradle staff have every single one where they
are what they're talking about edis logs it all even
generates a holographic record of each interaction That's
why we have the holographic records.
I was like, why are these being recorded?
And it's because Edis is just a little freakazoid who's just
like, yeah, this one's worth saving.
Well, that's just great.
Guess I better watch what I say.
Last thing I need is a penalty for saying the wrong thing.
Love that explanation.
Maybe I should keep my files offline until I get back to
Earth, just in case.
Or should I go old school with pen and paper?
Honestly, it might be the best option I got.
Let's try it out.
Not right now, Diana.
We have to go save the world.
We don't have time.
Oh, cool.
Everything is, I think, good?
Yep.
Very cool.
Let's...
Oh, yeah.
The last shot of non-primary units.
shot of like my shock wave gun and stuff like that that's
pretty that's kind of nice not gonna lie
here we go are there holographic records of anyone of
everyone taking a dump yes probably but maybe those aren't
important enough to store unless it's like a real doozy
Oh.
Hmm.
Okay.
I'm just gonna walk around that.
Oh,
it's this guy again.
You again?
Looks like the back
of it.
Yeah.
That was close.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
sometimes i wish i didn't have to hack in this game i know
there's auto hacking but at the same time i don't want to
have to like you know
please holy i didn't notice that
oh oh i think i missed that kind of sucks holy cow yeah it's
confused
We'll keep it confused
Keep it confused Keep it confused Until then I can use my
impact barrier Oh Um, riot blaster There we go Oh
Oh, there we go, there we go My stasis net Yeah, honestly
that might Ah!
You jerk?
No!
Oh, shoot.
Ah, shoot.
Let's corrupt it again, but...
No, it was just out of my range.
I'm gonna overdrive.
Yeah!
That's so rude!
That's such a rude feature!
Yeah, stupid.
Ah!
Charging!
Charging again.
Thank you!
Oh my god, ouch!
I lost my charge.
Get ready!
Holy shit!
Holy cow.
Oh, Stasis net!
Holy cow!
Almost there!
Impact barrier!
We'll start doing it here.
Where is he?
Actually, oh there he is.
Just shoot from him from here?
Helming missiles?
Nah, I'm good.
Nah, I win.
Oh!
Stasis!
Oh, did I get him?
Wait, I can't tell actually.
I think so?
Nice!
Yeah!
Take down the Sentinel!
Oh yeah!
Oh, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
What's this one?
Oh, the homing missiles again?
Expose.
Took him down with style.
Yeah, we did.
That was awesome.
Wait, which way is it?
Yeah.
I'm lost.
Didn't even use your heal.
I know, he only got me, like, very...
This is the Luna family.
Why am I climbing on buildings?
Or not buildings, on desks!
Hugh, please!
Yummy!
Pure Luna!
What does this say?
Dr. Higgins' availability.
Is it gonna tell me to see the secretary?
Yes!
Consultation hours are as follows.
One hour slots, reservations required.
May 23rd after 2 p.m.
Oh!
What day is it?
It's May 21st!
Oh, I can still get an appointment.
May 26th, after 2, after 5.
May 31st, after 8.
For scheduling, please contact the Secretary's Office.
Oh, I didn't grab it.
I just said, Wow, pretty, and then I put on my merry way.
Confidential.
Wait, it wanted us to read the email first.
It's been 10 days since Dr. Higgins shut himself away in his
lab.
Is there still no way to reach him?
Dr. Higgins is isolating himself to focus on his heavy
workload and is not available for communication.
Even the secretary's office has been unable to reach him.
Should he emerge from the lab, he may remain unapproachable
for some time.
So it is advisable to allow him the necessary space.
And then confidential.
Recent contamination report?
Note, this document must remain strictly within the Luna
Filament Lab Secretary's office until Dr. Higgins provides
further instructions.
Noah Parker, a former lab staff member, is unresponsive due
to advancing dead filament contamination, and shows no
reaction to external stimuli.
Did we hear this guy before?
I cannot remember him.
Furthermore, a visual examination conducted at 8 p.m.
8?
8.
At 8.
AM by a physician from the medical advancement lab indicates
that Parker's right arm right chest and lower jaw have
completely lost their original form due to contamination he
is likely deceased yikes 800 oh 800 hours give me one second
okay looks like Higgins have been out of contact for a I
don't think he liked getting involved with others.
Oh!
They took
her from me.
I warned them.
It was premature.
Again!
And again!
Well, it was fool.
To trust them.
Enough.
Ratwell.
Daisy, I'm sorry.
Don't shut the door on me.
That's how his daughter died.
That's awful.
Yeah, we know that, though.
Poor doctor.
Poor doctor indeed.
To my dearest Daisy.
I'm sorry, Daisy.
I couldn't save you.
I was there when you needed me most.
Your daddy's a complete fool.
Oh, I wasn't there when you needed me most.
The same thing happened when your mother passed.
I was already deep in research on the moon, experimenting
with lunar filament and living organisms, was the only one
who could save her.
I threw myself in my work.
It was all my selfishness.
My arrogance.
No, even so.
The clinical pragmatical trials were going well.
We were so close to seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel.
Why did it have to end like this?
Why did Delphi choose you, of all people?
I feel so empty now.
Daisy, I should have stayed with you.
I should have never come to the moon.
Is this a door?
No, I'll come.
Imagine if there's a hidden room in here.
I was hiding in my secret room when I heard Dr. Higgins
crying.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
There was something, the interaction thing now, over here.
This is the most advanced research lab in the entire cradle.
Higgins was probably right in that room.
Eight was with him, too.
There are traces up here.
I guess Eight was helping out the doctor more than I
expected.
She's carrying out the doctor.
The boss's will!
To destroy Earth and kill everybody that killed his
daughter!
Yeah, the moon?
Big mistake.
Get rid of it.
Unnecessary.
Oh.
Suddenly I'm walking.
Literally me.
You said curse them and she took it literally.
Cardiac arrest from acute exposure to dead filament
this is where he died dead filament huh
hugh okay back to work kiddo
oh geez the doctor's dead yeah
Oh, we can go around.
He left his work to eight.
Whoa, looks like a dentist in here.
Whoa, the music is so crazy.
Good evening to my fellow Aibuzan.
Good evening to my favorite freaky goose.
Look at very cute toys, sweet toys.
Thank you, Aikibario.
Thank you.
Good evening.
We are incoming the end, maybe?
What must be done?
Dr. Higgins, I wish to express the deep loneliness I'm
experiencing as I can no longer speak to you.
But worry not, before your body failed you, our time
together allowed me to reconstruct your fragmented memories
to fully understand you.
You were desperate to tell everyone about the true dangers
of dead filament.
I can make that happen.
By transforming the dead filament itself into a memory
medium and sending it to Earth as a singular universe.
unified being.
Everyone it touches will have come to understand your wish
directly.
Di33558.
I will deliver your will to Earth.
No matter the cost.
I don't think we'll be able to talk her down from this.
Better start preparing for the worst.
Oh, no.
No worries.
It'll be alright.
That does seem a of a leap i must i must also agree that's
our way into the orbital elevator all right let's go yeah
coming to stop you uh yeah we'll go back and we'll grab our
we'll we'll upgrade and also yeah i really okay for people
that beat this game is there a boss rush is there a standard
capcom boss rush
No?
Oh, good.
Let's see.
Let's, um...
We could do both, actually.
I have 14.
Recoil.
Let's actually do hacking.
And I'm also actually gonna do the suit.
You gotta fight 30 worms.
There isn't the DLC, but it's not really a rush.
Oh, really?
I
have two.
I don't have so much...
What's the word?
So much money.
So I'm thinking...
Maybe my homing missiles?
Lock on targets.
What is that?
Like, more targets it will lock onto?
We'll just see what happens.
If we need to come back, that's okay.
I mean, I would die, and then, you know.
You have to fight stronger versions of the bosses again in
the expansion, but it isn't a boss rush.
But in the expansion.
Yeah, now your gun won't shake 0.001% lows.
Why would you not go with a...
Homeming missile?
No.
Shockwave.
Homeming missile.
Gun.
Stasis net.
Riot blaster.
Decoi?
I'm not quite sure.
The both are good.
I feel like decoy is great too though.
There's less like going on in my face when I use the decoy.
Multi-hawk.
Not exposed.
We'll go.
We'll go with heat, maybe, and the health.
Okay.
My go-to build.
Laboratory!
Okay.
There needs to be an 8 skin for Diana.
Oh, that would be so good.
Actually, I fear that there's not enough skins for Diana.
Why does Hugh have so many skins and Diana has so few?
You know what I mean?
And through here?
No?
This way?
Through here?
That's all I gotta go.
My bad, Diana.
Oh my god.
I was jumping though.
Oh.
I just saw.
I just saw that thing.
Oh my god, there is one.
I had a feeling there would be one.
Oh my god, a roll outfit would be so good.
A roll outfit would be awesome!
Oh my god.
Okay, decoy.
Decoy.
Oh, I got God again.
My bad.
I tried to decoy, but...
Oh, I need to...
Oh shoot.
Oh shoot, I lost it.
Please, please, please last.
Please hold, please hold.
Oh my god, no!
No!
My decoy!
Stace is dead!
Screw you guys!
You guys are so...
You guys suck!
You guys suck so much!
Did I waste my first decoy?
That's so icky.
That's actually so icky.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I'm not.
I want to redo.
I wasted it on accident.
Because everything was happening.
Be careful.
Like this.
Ah!
Take this!
You bastard!
Okay.
The upgrade was good, I think.
I still
want to redo.
Dang it!
Oh, another decoy generator.
How kind of you.
Ouch.
Let's heal.
Turn it to survival horror for a second.
I messed it up so bad.
So frustrated.
Nang!
Oh, thank you, actually.
Oh.
How could you miss?
Wait.
It's fine, you made it past.
I know, but if only I hadn't messed up my...
It's fine.
I'm just being annoying.
oh shoot oh my god of course of course
so what's the projectiles coming from where are those coming
from oh i see it
whoa gamers don't look up I do.
Get ready.
Oh my gosh.
Why don't you guys get affected by this stuff?
Oh.
Hi friends.
Give me a sec.
Please.
Oh okay, we'll just have to...
Ah!
Oh.
Oh man, 90%?
Hurry, Hugh!
I'm on it!
Luckily it's kind of fragile.
It's like strong, but it's fragile.
Very annoying for sure.
Very annoying creature.
Um, is there anything?
Glass cannon.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm doing this so I can gather some more.
I don't think any other guy is.
My bad, Diana.
I don't
know if this does anything, but whatever.
Besides giving you money.
Might be a secret of some sort.
Someone said secret wall?
Wait, is it this?
Oh, it is!
What did he have here?
Thank you!
Thank you guys for being my eyes.
Oh.
What is down here?
Wait, this is much different than her other ones.
Shannon?
Wait, that's a...
Oh my god, no.
Are you kidding me?
Why are you doing in here?
What are you doing in her sanctuary?
Oh shoot, no!
You jerk.
Where are you?
Ah!
Leave it to me!
I got it.
It is kind of stupid.
No, no, no!
Yeah, there we go.
I had it so- I was so close to having it!
Wait, this room is completely covered.
Why?
I hope there's nobody else in here.
We can use that back at the shelter.
Uh-huh.
What is that, a photon laser?
Grab that.
Grab this.
Oh, sorry.
Just casually dying.
Oh, well we needed to come down here anyway.
I think?
Oh no, I guess this is our exit actually, just kidding.
Time to say goodbye!
Hold on.
Don't be rude.
Actually, I'm just going to hide you from my channel.
I don't know why you subscribed to me.
You're going to be like, she still hasn't finished the game.
Isn't this actually like a long game, though?
Lots of people have said that this is actually a long game.
It took up my spit.
Okay.
It's been three days since I got noticed to work at Dr.
Higgins' lab.
I thought it over and I made my decision.
I'm not going and I'm leaving Delphi.
I dug into this management AI a bit.
Oh my goodness.
I think 16 to 20 hours seems realistic.
If you're like...
I mean, I like to explore, so.
But if you just, like, go point to point without exploring,
I can see it being much shorter.
I don't even think that I, like, like I beat most bosses
first try, so it's not even, like, a matter of.
I keep dying.
They say sharing health bio data will allow rapid
integration with business systems and team asset
coordination.
It sounds plausible on the surface, but deep down, it's
thought.
control they just went to hurt us into following company
rules and grind us all the bones so they can squeeze every
last drop of efficiency from our poor little brains creating
life yeah right am I just being paranoid maybe but I can't
imagine being monitored every single moment at least they
can always start another project somewhere else guess it's
time to say farewell to my hideouts solitary as they were I
had my fair share of fun Sharon I hope she got out in time.
That's my worry.
Sharon, please be alive!
Hello?
I...
Oh, up here?
Oh, oh, whoa.
Neat.
Sharon, please be alive.
Oh, no!
It's okay, I have my...
I only have three health.
I don't want to know why.
Wait, this is a huge room.
Why is this room so big?
This room messed me up the most.
Oh,
this room.
Okay, this is an infamous room.
Got it.
Here I was talking about how I didn't die so much.
That might be.
This is the hardest of the end gauntlet for me.
Good luck, Mint.
You got it.
Oh gosh.
I might have... I might eat my words about having not died
so much.
What do I even have?
I do have a decoy generator still.
I only have homie missiles.
We'll save.
Okay.
Well, all I can do is go!
Oh, thank you.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared.
Oh, wait.
Hello, please!
Focus!
Good lord!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's this guy.
Okay.
Jump, cute!
Oh, whoa, everything exploded at once.
That was kind of cool.
Aww.
As we do, as we do.
I'm scared so far!
I'm scared!
Because so far it's so easy!
Why is it so easy?
So far?
Okay.
So far, it's too easy.
So far it's way too easy.
I'm scared!
Wait.
Keep going, I guess.
Because you're a pro.
No, I'm not.
Not even a little bit.
Okay, next part.
Oh, there's several.
Oh, my beloved shockwave gun!
Okay.
Oh, I see that up there.
See that.
Oh!
Woo!
That was a close one.
Baby!
Holy cow.
Ah!
Shoot!
It's just a normal baby.
Oh my god.
Why is he just standing there?
Um.
Right on.
Uh.
I wish I could reload faster.
Why is he just standing there?
Got him.
I'm saving my...
The PPs.
PPs,
PPs, PPs, PPs, PPs!
Actually, I don't...
Oh, it's up there!
Never mind, it's not the PPs.
So tanky, everything is so tanky.
Be careful.
Keep you strong.
Now it's my turn.
Oh.
I'm like trying to save my stall for now, but I'm like, is
it even worth it?
Right on.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
It's on now.
Take this.
Okay.
I'm like trying to save all my other stuff for future
things.
I come for it sooner.
Not really.
Oh,
I see there's the caution up there.
Oh, so I was in the easy part.
That makes so much sense.
Still have overdrive.
I'm holding on to it.
Dear life.
Here comes the real test.
Oh, they even let you print.
Why is it always the same thing?
I'm trying to fail.
out what could I guess stuff from the goo maybe I'm confused
also went that over there but I don't know how to get there
you got this okay if you say so oh yeah
okay I did a immediately guessing yeah oh
shoot I forgot that they don't they're not affected I have
to oh
dang it I thought it was a oh
my god
Uh...
Wait, this guy still needs to be...
Okay, got him.
Take this!
Uh,
the DQA is still good.
Diane, you okay?
Oh,
this guy's killer too, too.
So take this!
Oh!
Wait, but I have a...
Thing on him.
There we go.
Yeah!
Oh, that was it.
Oh!
Oh, I got all shaky for nothing.
the red room i don't even know where the red room is i'm not
i don't want to definitely not today maybe like member
streams if i ever want to do some uh uh other stuff you know
off street not off stream but you know like uh oh this is
the way i need to go okay cool hey stop this is my last
super on this account It's been nine months since I became
an Ibu app so much fun and streams I want to stay here and
continue supporting me Though I was a regular loyal Ibu Plus
there's a profile picture you drew from me So see you on my
new alt Wee Fuznab What do you mean?
What the heck?
Thank you!
I know it's you right?
You know how 8's trying to send death all of me to Earth,
right?
Do you really think that's what the doctor wanted?
Can't say, kiddo.
The doctor was in a bad spot there at the end.
Humans are a tough nut to crack.
Oh, that's not bad.
What's your best guess?
I think the doctor I knew wouldn't want all this.
If that's how you feel, then that's how it is.
You'll know.
Can I work for you?
I saw a box down there.
Data shard.
Wow!
You got me worried there.
I know I was worried too at first.
I was like, no!
Wait, there was something over here, wasn't there?
What's that blue?
It's a blue.
Lamau.
Fizz no!
Don't double Aqua Supa.
Welcome back.
Where's Noob?
Who could that be?
Oh my gosh, a new person.
Welcome to the channel.
New...
New Eye Boom!
Yummy!
upgrades upgrades we have 19 up 19 cubes
rumors of their demise we're greatly exaggerated this is a
really cool vista right whoa whoa yeah the whole game this
whole game has had amazing visuals if
Is this final boss?
It's so fun to collect.
Unlock every escape hatch!
Ah yeah.
Any advice on what weapons or what nodes or anything I
should bring?
My nerds.
What's up my nerds?
Can you tell me what nerds and nodes do?
bring back here again safe and snug safe and snug diana you
i i was really sad when i found out what happened to the
doctor did you just say no it's not multi-hack okay that's
all i need to know thank you but still i don't feel like
eight does Is that because I'm not as good as she is?
Eight has all the all the good genes.
That's not it.
You're just...
Diana got all the recessive genes.
I mean, yeah.
And in my eyes, I'm glad you're the way you are.
So, let's move on, okay?
Hmm.
I'm good.
I should just bring a pistol.
Okay.
Hmm.
Hacking?
We'll literally upgrade everything.
Well...
Oh.
I can't.
Well, it's fine.
My primary unit literally was just the recoil that I was
only going to be able to upgrade at this point.
Sentientry, welcome back!
Thank you!
I used decoy, but Shield will be good.
Shield over decoy, perhaps?
Hmm.
Okay.
Go at it.
Um, riot blaster.
If that is the case, I will up the riot blaster.
Damage ammo capacity.
In fact, I'll do it again.
You can't stop me!
I could even do it one more time!
Nah.
She'll one-shot the decoy.
Shall we...
Does StasisNet...
I'm sorry.
I keep asking you guys questions.
I'll figure it out if StasisNet will work on her or not.
I'll figure it out.
I think StasisNet, right, gone.
I think most of the stuff that I've had will even do...
Oh, I forgot to do my thrusters.
You know what?
It's fine.
My thrusters are, like, near perfect.
I'll do repair up, though.
Oh, I have a cabin coin.
New training sim data has arrived.
I can't resist VTubers asking questions.
You know this.
Stasis is also pretty good, essentially.
Whatever feels good for you to use.
I think basically what I did this past, like that past room,
like that's what I feel comfortable with, you know what I
mean?
Bingo bingo!
Oh yes, this is one of our more popular items.
Oh yes.
Okay, bye.
Please enjoy your purchase.
I imagine her like zip zooming around, just like via a
little, you know.
Oh, and then she also, she had, they showed her with those
like, those projectiles.
So, okay, let's see.
Shockwave homing.
Stasis.
Riot blaster.
Impact barrier.
Not multi-hack, we'll do drain and freeze and heat.
Okay.
Let's go!
Orbital elevator access!
I'm nervous how this game is going to end.
I'm nervous.
Those kids be zooming.
She moves like a gremlin?
Godspeed, Minto.
this if i don't got this i can change the difficulty but
i've got can you imagine getting through the entire game on
one difficulty and then changing it at the last boss that
sounds so silly nah you got this yeah i believe too i have
to get this you hurry i'm going it's kind of like there's no
other option you know is that is that hurt that is her oh
wow what an arena it's this feels it's worse it's like
almost devil may cry she is so small I know right do the
stealth kill for real though she's waiting for us yeah we
have to save Earth!
Voodle in his chair.
So how's the packing coming?
I'm packing days!
Oh, thanks to you.
The shipment for Earth is almost ready.
I have nearly fulfilled my purpose.
Gonna wipe out the purpose we were meant to share.
Why share?
Whoa!
Nice dodge.
No, I decide my own way.
I'm going to Earth with you.
You still don't understand.
You are pragmatic.
Yeah!
So what?
She's more than that.
Mm-hmm.
And she's not something for you to use and throw away.
Yeah.
You're beyond repair.
Who's she talking to there?
Me or her?
Kew?
This is where we part ways for good.
Yes.
Whoa.
No, Virgil, no!
No!
No robot virtual!
Taito!
The orb!
Whoa!
Wow!
So cool!
Okay, here we go, I'm scared.
Wee!
Oh
no.
Oh, the music is so good!
Ouch.
Oh, I'm not even in there.
Or she's not even in there.
Oh, watch out, watch out, watch.
God is in my own wrong.
Oh my gosh, it's really hard to...
Watch out.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Dead filament.
Go away!
Holy cow, okay.
Can I even, like...
I'm gonna try Stasis net again.
Okay.
She like...
Run, run, run.
Oh!
Nice!
It was too late.
Doing like so little damage to her.
Oh,
dang it.
I gotta jump there.
Oi!
What is she doing?
Is she healing?
No.
I don't think so.
I don't think she healed.
She does.
It's so goofy.
It's so hard to keep her open!
Because it's...
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Ah.
Cleanse the child.
Oh my gosh, I'm not reading her attacks at all.
I'm struggling.
Oh
my god, I've done so little damage to her.
Oh, everything's so far.
How am I supposed to...
Oh, kill!
Uh-oh.
Rout roll.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is crazy!
I can't do
that Oh
my god It's still coming after me Leave me alone I
got greedy My bad It's so hard to
Wait am I supposed to cleanse her That's what you guys meant
by cleansing That's what you guys meant by cleansing I
thought you were just saying cleanse the child like set her
free
Give her a bath
You took us to metaphorically
Ouch, Ouch Oh wait, I need to
Did I get her?
No, you Oh,
she's doing it again for me.
I can't
believe that.
I can't believe I just...
Dang it.
Ah!
Doing so high.
Sometimes I can dodge that.
Sometimes I can.
I think we're...
I think I'm gonna have to probably read this one again.
See you!
Oh, jeez.
Cleanse her again.
Yeah, I will.
No!
She broke out!
Hold on, you!
I'll see what I can do.
Oh, shoot.
Nice!
I have no heals left though.
We're so, it's so over for us.
Oh my god.
No more second guessing, Diana.
Just do it.
I am
the one.
Ouch.
My god.
Ah!
Ouch!
You sucker!
Oh, I failed it again.
Do I need to cleanse her again?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, the cow.
Good enough.
Sheesh!
Oh, geez.
Uh-oh, guys.
Uh-oh.
She's insane.
She's insane!
Good hack.
I don't know, though.
It's not this stinking ball again.
Yeah, you're telling me.
Okay.
I think you have it next run.
Maybe, yeah.
No.
Now that I realized I was making it more hard on myself.
I can't believe I'm so stinking stupid.
Hey, remember that thing that we introduced that you've been
doing?
Also, hopefully I can, um, my hacking gauge.
Okay, awesome first try without cleanse.
We were doing something, honestly.
Oh, it's so funny.
Okay, I know it's maybe not the best setup, but Stasis Net
and then Impact Barrier.
And then Freeze.
Drain.
And Heat.
Okay, let me see what my mods are currently.
Okay, HP.
I don't need the 10% more filament.
Open enemy state exposed.
Increase hacking range will do that.
Quick fix will do that.
We can do the self-defense response.
Reduces damage received by 20% when your HP is below 50.
If she wasn't goopy, you would have fried her.
Heat build.
What's fast moves?
Is that like my dodge?
gauge fills 10% faster.
That one, honestly,
perfect dodge.
I was doing quite a bit of those, so.
Time slows down when you dodge.
Let's try the heat gauge.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Let's try heat transfer.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, getting her down more is important for sure
then me like going into slow-mo and accidentally missing
okie dokie
key build peak I think it's so fun that you can do builds in
this game I love games that let you that allow you to play
as you feel comfortable with I believe Eight is controlling
all that black stuff.
This ain't gonna be a walking apart, that's for sure.
I think I can stop Eight's attacks.
I got this, Hugh.
Yep.
Coming in early?
Where's she at?
You still have no clue.
We'll stop you no matter what.
Hopefully it's still there.
That'd be so funny if it isn't.
That's right, bitch!
I guess she didn't need it.
I thought she was doing it again.
No!
She's going!
Yeah!
Okay, is this thing?
Pick damage!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh,
dang it, I missed it.
becoming evil again?
Holy cow.
Did I?
Oh, dang it.
Oh,
nice.
Oh, nice.
You know what?
I should do this.
Nice!
You know what?
I should do this too.
I don't know why I haven't yet.
Chocolate.
Homeing missiles?
Oh.
Baby.
Now your fate is sealed.
I'm going to send you to help me.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
I am the only one who understands your fear.
I am sad.
Teal?
Uh...
Okay.
You have no purpose.
Awesome.
Look out!
Come on!
Okay.
Riot Blaster?
Maybe?
Shoot!
The heat going up is kind of insane, actually.
It's like so fast.
Oh, no, no, that's not the way I wanted to go.
Where is she doing?
What is she doing?
Oh.
It's freezing that crap!
Holy cow.
When does it end?
Oh my god.
Where should she go?
Charging!
Whoa!
I'm here.
It's coming!
Yes!
I wish that was more.
It felt like it should have been much more.
Can I get her?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah!
Nice.
Man, getting the heat bonus was...
Oh, my gosh.
That was a game changer.
Virgil.
I can't get over.
How similar.
Hey.
Tell them all.
Earth must know.
His pain.
His suffering.
His final days.
I must tell them.
Transport's at the top of the...
Why did I need to know?
Doctor.
Oh, you better, baby.
Oh, messed up Minto cackles while fighting child.
Boss, you killed a child.
Great work.
That's why you're the best!
Evil child.
Oh, no!
She got reduced to goop!
Hugh knows that there's not much time.
Oh, reduced to goop.
Goop Virgil.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
It stirs.
Oh, the game just saved.
Diana?
I can walk through you.
That's a little freaky.
Diana.
You okay?
Yeah.
I couldn't save her, but...
At least we got to talk.
I'm sorry.
I know it's hard, but we can't slow down.
There should be a transport for us at the top.
And go to Earth?
But time's not on our side.
You?
We'll be alright.
Just think about what you're gonna do once we're back on
Earth.
What I'm gonna do?
Race yourself.
You gotta see the ocean, right?
Or you want to do some bird watching?
I want to do both.
That's a spirit?
Let's go, kiddo.
I don't want to look at her.
What you're gonna do, not weir.
Oh, no!
Why do you decide to take me with you?
Uh-oh.
More goop?
Now what?
I was gonna say imagine it's a worm Oh, this is much bigger
than a worm Look, the dead filament is back
It's out of control We can't leave it like this They can
follow us to earth Eraser Whoa A railgun
Oh my god Holy cow That thing is sick There you are I was a
lot like you.
A thirst for life and all its mysteries.
Oh, boy.
Q becomes Metal Gear!
A few bumps along the way.
But I had someone.
Someone looking out for me.
And now it's your turn.
A whole new life.
If you're ready.
Okay, then let's go.
Together.
Yeah!
Is this the BFG?
Actually, though.
Wait, am I actually...
fighting this thing do I control it
whoa okay waiting waiting and oh you get ready to shoot are
we ready yet no no wait what do you mean no target
It'd be really embarrassing to die here.
Okay.
Oh!
Dodge you!
Okay, one second I gotta take off my headphones and start to
hurt my ears.
Here it goes!
I'm charging!
Target!
Yeah!
That was close.
You know what I think?
Yeah, Diana!
Oh, geez.
Doing something.
We're, like, going into space.
Get lost!
This thing is so freaky!
Yeah, I'm alright.
I'm gonna do it way worse.
We're waiting.
Yeah!
Oh,
this is the fastest way up the elevator, I guess.
maybe not fast what the hell is this optimizing hacking with
tricks initiate whoa wait where oh
i dealt 3 000 damage to it the shuttle the shuttle No.
No.
I think this will work.
We're gonna go.
Bye.
We're gonna propel ourselves.
Not like this.
Let me try.
.
Yeah.
Eat laser!
Filament.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I cannot tell if like it's gonna be...
Wait, I cannot tell...
Who's gonna survive with us?
My, my beam!
But I'm fine.
She's okay.
We're a good thing we upgraded our right I like that we're
using our butt boosts he will
be okay right you
are you okay don't worry I made a promise right better yet
or suit is like turbo turbo done on earth you can walk for
yourself hey I i can walk you sure i do it all the time here
look i'm walking perfectly fine you're gonna need shoes on
earth little missy back on me in no time that's not true oh
there she goes running ahead of us can't rely on me forever
you know
oh gosh we're getting slower i'll do whatever it takes get
you back to earth no matter what
oh there's a cargo ship really oh microwave hallway of
emotion I know we already have one microwave hallway can we
go to earth in that yeah I just pull this off Diana what Q
Thanks.
No problem.
Is this how we're going to Earth?
Not for human use.
It is what it is.
Wait, what's...
There can't be more!
There's a room for only one.
She's so cute.
I fit.
but it'll do what about you explosions messed everything up
full automation is not an option gotta push it to the end of
the rail hang tight okay
you is everything all right yeah it's a heavy bugger i want
to help stay put it's too risky let me
hack it what about cabin just gotta give it a bit of the old
elbow grease
again you
bad news this is where we say goodbye
Sorry, Squirt.
No, I want to stay with you.
It's okay.
You're going to be okay.
Go find the scene.
No, wait!
Have a safe journey.
Get
out of here.
Do you remember the reason that we walked along?
The place that you promised me you'd take me one day.
But you taught me how beautiful our life is
The gift that you give me the day Since then, when I see a
globe, it reminds me of
Nooo I wonder though, like for him, how he got, how he got
contaminated.
It's starting to get heavier and heavier, but I was trying
to walk along with it.
Oh yeah, with the... thing.
Ugh.
You had a hard life.
Oh, man.
We knew it was coming, too, from, like, when we saw that he
was infected.
Man.
Cutscene spears cannot be dodged
Thank you guys for the gift Yeah they wave the flag so early
too right we'll go see the sea together his last line to her
saying go find the sea
you asked in subtle way if diana could clean the dead
filament i know when he asked that when he was like could
you say could you help them and she's like no and it's like
oh man you know he's asking for himself cleanse the child
Yeah, they did pretty much, like, not shove it in your face.
There was just a lot of flags, but then, you know, it still
gets you feeling.
Because Hugh is just so good.
He's such a good main character.
Regardless of, like, him staying with...
Toei Shukun!
them for my 3d birthday but um regardless of like if you're
like oh i want them to you know go to earth together you
just also don't want them to die or or rather you don't want
wait as much as you're like oh i don't want them to die wait
opposite sorry my brain
hope core character dies no They knew we'd never believe it
had a happy ending and confirmed us early.
Because the main menu was too sad.
All of the music in this game was too sad.
They were like, hey, buckle up, buckle.
You're in for an emotional ride.
There is a secret ending.
Is there no?
How do you...
Well, is it...
First question.
Is it spoilers to tell me how you obtain that secret ending?
Because otherwise I was gonna say how...
Oh, it's post-cam.
Oh, okay.
Oh, not really a secret then.
You have to collect everything?
You have to basically 100%.
Got it.
I was gonna rag on Capcom for having another giant eyeball
weak spot mutant railgun fight.
But not today.
The vocal trap dropped.
was unfair and moi.
Right!
Oh, the vocal track.
And you're like, no, in the piano.
And you're like, no!
Elfis, no!
Thank you!
She prepared Diana for the world to head like a true dad.
Such a good game.
I'm glad I got to beat it today.
I'm glad we got to beat it today.
Are you getting so hard today?
Thank you.
No,
Isaac and Labardori!
Thank you, Shabu.
If you haven't watched my birthday live, even though it was
from my birthday, I recommend it.
It was fun.
Creatile blocking in and saving Diana.
I guess we kind of saved the moon because we destroyed the
thing, the filament, right?
So we did kind of save the moon.
I mean, the moon was kind of unsalvageable by the time we
got there anyway.
Congrats, Aminto.
Thank you!
Oh, her little feet.
She's walking such small steps.
What do you... What do you do when you... Oh my god!
That guy is so cute!
Also, she couldn't even cry.
They didn't like...
Give her...
Android tears!
Pride by Extreme Beach Volleyball.
Shut up.
Aww, this is a nice wallpaper, I think.
Right?
Aww.
Ready?
What does that mean?
Complete the game on any difficulty.
Our promise.
Well.
Congratulations on completing the story.
You have now created completed saved data.
Carry your completed saved data in a new game plus to
restart the story and enhance state.
Are we going to new game mode?
Unknown signal.
Unknown.
Oh.
Unknown signal.
I think I've got to go check wallpaper engine right after
this to see if somebody made one for Diana.
On the back.
beach but like what do you do even if you're just a robot
you're on earth like what oh cute diana's pink pop outfit
hugh's astro classic type b cute jackhammer it will now
appear in your unit printer and you can be printed and
upgraded in all game modes what the heck is that their game
plus is now over parts of your completed save data and start
the story from the beginning and enhance state oh the first
boss that was so long ago oh and attack difficulty this high
stakes difficulty is for players who want a sense of
catharsis after overcoming a difficult challenge enemies
will be much stronger and a variety of units can be printed
from the start of the game completing the story also unlocks
new weapon functions
Yeah, what's this?
This mode adds new content to your save data just before
completing the game.
Overcome new challenges to earn special rewards like weapons
and outfits.
Oh.
We're not...
It's not them together anymore.
It's not them sitting in the cabin anymore.
Unknown signal is the secret ending.
Maybe you can watch the ending on YouTube.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it long?
I imagine probably not.
Great job getting through those tough bits at the end.
I played this because of how much fun you were having with
it.
Thank you, Rinto.
I hope you had just as much fun, Rickadan.
Once I got back into it, I really enjoyed getting back into
it.
It's very short.
Like three seconds?
It's only five seconds.
It's literally five seconds of dialogue.
You get one extra line.
That's craziness.
Oh, was that a shooting star?
Or was my monitor acting up?
My monitor's been acting up recently, so...
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
Let me see if I can pull it up.
Um...
What was it?
Oh.
Pragmata?
Secret ending.
All of these are like...
They're like 30 minutes long.
I just want that... I just want the final bit!
Go find the sea.
I bought this game because I used to think you've been told.
I had lots of fun playing and watching you finish the game.
Again, sorry it took me so long to beat it.
But I'm glad that I finally did.
Yippee!
We did it!
Another game in the belt.
Again, I really like this game because I felt like I got a
handle of the controls pretty well.
It ended up being so fun to me.
Hmm.
If I would love, like, if we ever get Devil May Cry, another
Devil May Cry, you know?
If we ever get another Devil May Cry,
like similar probably though people wouldn't like it very
much because it would be kind of different from the original
devil may cry but you know maybe at 100 there are but it
just says like there's one like how to unlock okay hold on
i'm gonna open up one of the videos real quick and then i'll
just skip to it i'll just like skip the boss and everything
okay oh one second okay post credit Okay, sorry for whoever,
whatever outfit they're using.
It might be a, actually this looks like a bit of a spoiler
outfit.
So I apologize, let's, hold on.
Oh, it's so cute though.
We'll just watch this, okay, let's see.
We'll just watch the beach scene again.
I want to see that crab.
All right, window capture.
Pragmata.
So this is spoilers as well for the secret ending in case
you were wanting to play the game to get it yourself.
So, wait, let me make sure that it's not like, okay.
Hard to tell the crop, honestly.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's watch.
Where'd that crowd at?
All them boys.
Little seagulls.
The outfit
is so stinking cute.
Whoa, the horns!
It's like a dragon outfit.
Oh, I just realized both games are playing piano at the same
time.
I'm sorry.
I'm ready.
Dueling piano.
Sorry.
All bad.
Talk to this?
What's this?
Traveling alone today?
Oh, oh, sorry.
This person.
Thank you.
Ben Gunn for letting me use her channel.
Oh, wait.
So we made it back?
How?
And that's it.
But that's like huge.
I still think.
I think at the same time.
I still think that's huge.
Oh, there's also, hold on.
There's this image, but I'm trying to get the guys...
Oh, hide, here we go.
You get a trophy.
Hold on, look at this.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, I already exited out of it.
No!
Wait, hold on.
You get like a little photo.
Come on.
I'm pulling it up myself.
Look how cute that is!
Finn.
Aww!
I mean it really sets it up for if there's a Pragmata too.
Can he even survive though?
Like is it like almost- is it still a death sentence to him?
But I- but!
Diana could be like, he could send a signal, or Diana could
be like, we got to go get Hugh and send people to go rescue
him.
Hmm.
So, you know.
Unless he can cure himself.
He's a genius and figures it out himself.
But yeah, that was Pragmata.
Still hits into Kokoro.
Kokoro, brokoro.
Ugh.
Thanks for streaming, Mint.
Thank you for being here.
Thanks for watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed Pragmata.
Because I did a longer stream today, I still am streaming
tomorrow.
Maybe short stream on Saturday.
Very, very short.
Something easy.
Solidare.
I can beat Forbidden Solitaire on Saturday, maybe.
but yeah I probably will stream Saturday not Sunday for
after Faname and all
but yeah thanks for being a good dad to Diana boss my eyes
remain wet and I know me too I'm gonna go eat dinner now and
I suggest you do the same thank you guys for helping me out
and encouraging me and Good day, have a good night, have a
good time, Joan.
Thank you for the encore.
I think you can thank you guys.
There was an encore super earlier too, and I was crying too
much.
Thank you so much.
Hope you rest well.
Actually, let me find it.
I don't want to go without saying thank you.
One second.
Nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna, nna.
Where is it?
No.
Oh, supers.
Supers.
Rune of Collusion, thank you.
Thank you.
And the Metal Gear reference.
No.
I'm all extra snotty now.
What a good game.
Thanks for playing, Mint.
Thank you.
I'm really glad that I initially got sponsored for this.
Because maybe I would have picked it up later.
or something like that i don't know but i'm glad that i
picked it up yeah have a good rest you as well i'm having a
nighttime pancake with cocoa chips i have some leftovers
with some leftover offerings so i'll eat that everybody oh
thank you thank you thank you have a good day have a good
night bye bye bye get some good rest thank you for the long
stream Bye bye, bye bye I feel like because the song and the
title screen is so soft I have to be soft I feel like it's
somber and everything Bye bye bye See you What's up,
everyone?
Bye bye